Hi Josh, Craig and Alec, I'm Kate and I live in Corsica.
嗨，乔什、克雷格和亚历克，我是凯特，我住在科orsica（科西嘉岛）。
I wanted to thank you for your amazing podcasts, which I find just as comforting as the show has always been to me, and even more philosophical.
我想感谢你们制作了这么棒的播客，对我来说，它们和这部剧本身一样充满慰藉，甚至更具哲学意味。
I'm definitely meeting at the show with new eyes.
我绝对是用全新的视角在重温这部剧。
And something I took from what you said and you say it over and over again, which is great for me.
我从你们说的话里学到了一点，而且你们反复说过这一点，这对我帮助很大。
It's like my new motto is people will dance.
就像我的新座右铭一样：“人们会跳舞的”。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我不会为此担心的。
As a hypersensitive person, I always worry about what people are thinking.
作为一个高度敏感的人，我总是担心别人在想什么。
And another thing is I recently started singing in a band.
还有一件事是，我最近开始在一个乐队里唱歌。
Something I've always wanted to do and I've never dared to do because I was always worried and didn't have the confidence.
这是我一直想做的事，但以前从不敢尝试，因为我总是担心，而且缺乏自信。
I now sing on stage, and I'm always worried people aren't going to dance and not enjoy themselves.
我现在会在舞台上唱歌，我总是担心大家不会跳舞、不会玩得开心。
So I always say that to myself before I go on stage, people will dance, I'm not gonna worry about it.
所以我每次上台前都会对自己说：“人们会跳舞的，我不会为此担心。”
So thank you for this motto which I will take and use for the rest of my life.
所以，谢谢你们给了我这个座右铭，我会一直带着它，在余生中使用。
Thank you guys.
谢谢你们，伙计们。
Hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《老爸老妈的浪漫史》幕后揭秘。
I'm your co-host, Josh Radner.
我是你们的联合主持人乔什·拉德诺。
My other co-host is Craig Thomas.
我的另一位联合主持人是克雷格·托马斯。
He's here with me.
他就和我在一起。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey there, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Craig co-created a show with Carter Bay years ago called How I Met Your Mother.
多年前，克雷格与卡特·贝斯共同创作了一部名为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的剧集。
I starred in that show as Ted Mosby and now we're working our way through we're looking back And we're having the best time and we are also delighted every week to receive letters and voice notes And I was just so delighted by that By that people will dance has become someone else's Inspirational motto that has that has outsides impact that line from the pilot like it's not like we shot the pilot We're like that line people are gonna get tattoos of that line.
我在剧中饰演泰德·莫斯比，现在我们正在重温这部剧，回顾过去，我们度过了非常美好的时光。每周我们也很高兴能收到大家的信件和语音留言。听到“人们会跳舞的”这句话成了别人的励志座右铭，产生了意想不到的影响，我真的非常高兴。就像试播集里的那句台词，当时我们拍试播集时，可没想到“人们会纹这句台词的纹身”。我们还会听到来自科西嘉岛的听众的声音——顺便说一句，我去过科西嘉岛。
We're gonna hear from people in Corsica by the way, I've been to Corsica.
顺便说一句，我去过科西嘉岛。
It's unbelievably beautiful.
那里美得难以置信。
During how I met your mother, I visited Corsica.
在拍《老爸老妈的浪漫史》期间，我参观过科西嘉岛。
I think very early on, it's really gorgeous there.
我想那是在很早的时候，那里真的很漂亮。
And can you imagine, Josh, that line is coming back to us, boomeranging back to us from Corsica.
你能想象吗，乔什，那句话又回到了我们身边，像回旋镖一样从科西嘉岛飞回了我们这里。
Well, I also would like to say, we kind of touched on this when Wayne Brady joined us.
嗯，我还想说，之前韦恩·布雷迪加入我们时，我们曾稍微聊到过这个话题。
But the notion that just because you have stayed trident because you're nervous as nothing to do with your talent or your ability.
但这种观点——仅仅因为你感到紧张、因为你害怕，就和你的才华或能力毫无关系。
And it reminded me that Natalie Merchant from 10,000 Maniacs, one of, I think, like, the great vocalists of fun at time, was apparently so nervous and struck with stage fright in her early years of 10,000 Maniacs that she would only perform with her back to the audience.
这让我想起了“一万个狂热分子”乐队的娜塔莉·麦商特，我认为她是那个时代最伟大的歌手之一。据说她在“一万个狂热分子”早期的演出中非常紧张、患有严重的舞台恐惧症，以至于她只能背对着观众进行表演。
Oh my God.
噢天哪。
She's like Miles Davis.
她就像迈尔斯·戴维斯一样。
Yeah, she's faced the band because she could not face the audience, but I don't think it matters.
对，她面对着乐队，因为她无法面对观众，但我觉得这没关系。
It doesn't matter.
这没关系。
You know, people will dance.
你知道的，人们会跳舞的。
We're not going to worry about it.
我们不会担心的。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞的。
going to worry about it.
不会担心的。
It's the best.
这太棒了。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你分享这些。
And those messages are the best part of this little thing.
这些留言是我们这个小节目中最棒的部分。
Please keep sending them in.
请继续发给我们。
We love to hear from people how the show has landed on them, how they're growing with it, how they're even how they're reconsidering it as they get older, as we're doing here.
我们喜欢听大家分享这部剧带给他们的触动、他们是如何随着剧集一同成长的，甚至是如何在随着年龄增长重新审视它的——就像我们现在这样。
Today we are, we're deep into season two of How I Met Your Mother.
今天，我们深入探讨了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》第二季的内容。
This is an episode called First Time in New York.
这一集名为《纽约初体验》。
It was written by whom?
它是谁写的？
This was written by Gloria Calderon-Kellitt, and it aired on January 8th, 2007.
这一集由格洛丽亚·卡尔德龙·凯利特编剧，于2007年1月8日播出。
So, auspicious moment, beginning of a new year.
这是一个好兆头，是一年新开始的时刻。
And this, our podcast episode will also be dropping in January of the New Year, right?
而且我们这期播客节目也将在新年的1月份发布，对吧？
This episode is dropping around that same time.
这一集的发布时间也差不多在那个时候。
So, it seems like the podcast, it always feels like we're 19 years ahead of the, 19 years down on the down stream.
所以，感觉我们的播客就像是比现实慢了19年，落后了19年的时间。
But this is a really fun episode.
但这真是一集非常有趣的节目。
This is what I call these episodes like filling in the lore.
这就是我所说的那些“补充背景设定”的剧集。
Like when there's these flashback episodes, you get like more of the history of people and it kind of shades in and adds more color to the sketch.
就像当有这些闪回情节时，你能了解到更多关于角色的历史，这就像是为草图添枝加叶，增添了更多色彩。
And I always love these episodes.
我一直很喜欢这样的剧集。
I remember this was a fun one to film.
我记得拍摄这一集非常有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think that's a good way to put a filling in the lore.
我觉得用“补充背景设定”来形容很贴切。
It doesn't necessarily advance the present day story wildly except Robin saying I love you to Ted is a huge step in their relationships.
它不一定会对当下的故事产生疯狂的推动作用——除了罗宾对泰德说“我爱你”，这是他们关系中的一大步。
I like that about it.
我很喜欢这一点。
A feeling on the lore episode is great if in the end of the sum move, some chess move happens.
如果到最后产生了一些类似下棋走子般的剧情推动，那么一集补充背景设定的剧集就会非常棒。
It's also important in the presence, which I appreciated about this episode, but I loved getting to see these characters and how they lost their virginity.
它在当下也很重要，我很欣赏这一集的这一点，但我更喜欢看到这些角色以及他们是如何失去童贞的。
Like once we hit that idea in the writer's room, we're like, this is juicy.
就像我们在编剧室里一旦想到这个点子，我们就觉得：这太有看点、太带劲了。
We'll dive into this.
我们要深入探讨这个。
And also a genius title for this.
而且这一集的标题也太天才了。
First time in New York.
《纽约初体验》。
Great title.
好名字。
I would not change.
我不会改的。
This is the title.
这就是剧名。
No, perfection.
不，完美。
10 out of 10.
满分10分。
would do again.
还会再拍一次。
I think Gloria, the writer of the episode, maybe came up with that.
我想这一集的编剧格洛丽亚可能想出了这个名字。
She was very entitled.
她非常适合起标题。
You know what else was funny?
你知道什么也很有趣吗？
It struck me in this episode like because you're at 8.30 on prime time 20 years ago, you're still dealing with a pretty heavy-handed standards and practices department.
这一集让我印象深刻的是，因为你是在20年前的黄金时段8点半播出，你仍然要应付一个相当严厉的审查和标准部门。
Yeah, for sure.
是的，确实如此。
Now, this episode is about sexual intercourse, your first time having sex.
现在，这一集是关于性行为的，是你第一次发生性关系的经历。
That's what this episode is largely about.
这集的大部分内容都在讲这个。
But it's almost entirely euphemistic.
但它几乎全是用委婉的说法来表达的。
It is.
确实如此。
It's very domestic.
非常含蓄。
Except for the part where you we apparently see Robin, we sort of are seeing that happen with Robin.
除了我们似乎看到罗宾的那部分，我们好像看到那种事发生在罗宾身上。
I was like, that was a big swing.
当时我觉得：这尺度可真大。
And no one, none of the standards perhaps people said, wait a second, did we just see quasi intercourse happen in this scene, which, which it seems to be strongly implied.
而且没有任何一个审查部门的人说：“等一下，我们刚刚是不是在这场戏里看到了类似性交的画面？”虽然这似乎被强烈暗示了。
I mean, then it's debated, but later, when they pop back, I'm getting a little ahead of ourselves.
我是说，后来他们还对此进行了争论，但后来当他们闪回时……我是不是有点剧透了。
But when they pop back, and he said, oh, no, my mom's home.
但当他们闪回时，他说：“哦，不，我妈在家。”
Like, I didn't understand the joke.
当时我没听懂这个笑话。
And Jordana had to explain it to me.
乔丹娜不得不向我解释。
You have to be very much paying attention.
你必须非常专心地看。
You have to be paying attention because it's the room is like filled with posters of like Teen Idol, like a heartthrob guy, right?
你必须全神贯注，因为那个房间里贴满了青少年偶像的海报，比如那种万人迷帅哥的画报，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
对，对，绝对是的。
But she says there were signs he was gay, because you assume it's her room, right?
但她说有迹象表明他是同性恋，因为你以为那是她的房间，对吧？
Yeah, you assume it's her room.
对，你以为那是她的房间。
And the A said, yeah, that was last night with Rebecca who also hadn't seen the episode in 18 years and my wife and she there was a delayed reaction, but then it was her biggest laugh realization.
艾（A）说：“对，那是昨晚的事。”丽贝卡也是18年没看过这一集了，还有我妻子，她们都有点延迟反应，但随之而来的就是最大的笑点和顿悟。
That was his room.
那是他的房间。
She had a huge laugh.
她当时爆发出巨大笑声。
It's a real slow burn that one.
那个包袱的回味时间可真长啊。
Yeah, it's a way home, or is this a satellite delay?
是啊，你是说在回家的路上笑，还是卫星信号有延迟？
You mean laugh on your way home?
你是说在回家的路上才笑出来吗？
Live on your way home.
在你回家的路上收听。
Or I've also heard it described, maybe this was a Rob Greenberg.
或者我也听人这样描述过，也许这是罗布·格林伯格说的。
You open the refrigerator at night and then you laugh.
你半夜打开冰箱，然后笑了出来。
Yeah, like you're looking for food late at night and that's what it hits you.
对，就像你深夜在找吃的，然后那种感觉突然就击中了你。
Oh, yeah, it's I get it.
哦，对，我懂。
No, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It also is an interesting one about, because we go into everyone else's kind of virginity, losing their virginity stories.
这也是一个很有趣的话题，因为我们聊到了其他所有人的童贞，也就是他们失去童贞的故事。
It's an interesting thing of like the stories we tell others versus the stories we tell ourselves.
这是一个很有意思的事情，关于我们讲给别人听的故事与我们讲给自己听的故事之间的区别。
Yes, yes, it's a good one in that category.
是的，是的，在这个类别里这是一个很棒的故事。
And there's a really funny, we'll get into this, but Barney's thing is really funny, meets incredibly tragic, meets back to being hilarious.
而且还有一个非常搞笑的——我们待会儿会聊到，巴尼的经历真的是既好笑又极其悲惨，最后又回到了爆笑。
Part of his like scarred origin story of why he is the way he is in this one, yeah.
这也是他那饱经沧桑的身世背景的一部分，解释了他为什么会是现在这样，对吧。
And how, yeah, we'll get into it.
以及，是的，我们会详细聊到。
We'll say that till the end.
我们把这个留到最后再说。
But so we opened this episode musically.
不过，这集我们是以音乐开场的。
I was just listening to the Ted Mosby architect episode we did, but we were talking, I was open talking a ton about music, but we opened with a weepy song, right?
我刚才还在听我们做的那集关于泰德·莫斯比建筑师的那期，当时我们谈论了很多关于音乐的事情，但我们是用一首伤感的歌开场的，对吧？
Isn't the weepy song?
那首不就是伤感的歌吗？
Yeah, the weepy song.
对，那首伤感的歌。
Yeah, which I think Gloria also brought in the writer of the episode.
对，我想格洛丽亚也带来了这集的编剧。
I think she brought us that.
我想是她把这个带给我们的。
And Gloria, I believe, was the one who recommended the Decemberist song.
而且我记的没错的话，格洛丽亚就是推荐那首“The Decemberists”乐队歌曲的人。
Gloria was a real- Yeah, Gloria made a kick-ass mix that had a few really good songs on it.
格洛丽亚真的是——对，格洛丽亚做了一张非常棒的混音带，里面有几首非常好的歌。
And for season two, and we used, Yeah, the December's was on there and the weepies was on there.
为了第二季，我们用了——对，“The Decemberists”的歌在里面，“The Weepies”的歌也在里面。
Yeah, again, a great kind of indie, I mean, the weepies, again, were, I think, just breaking around that time.
是的，又是一支非常棒的独立乐队，我是说，“The Weepies”在那个时候也是刚开始崭露头角。
Like, we were really catching people or catching bands.
就像我们真的在关注那些人或那些乐队一样。
Where did, do you remember how this episode was broken, like, what was the, what was the germ of this?
这集是怎么构思出来的，你还记得吗，它的核心或者说最初的灵感是什么？
I think we won.
我想我们赢了。
I mean, I think we love the idea of everyone's virginity story.
我是说，我觉得我们很喜欢每个人的初夜故事这个主意。
We liked the idea of meeting a sibling, right?
我们喜欢见一个兄弟姐妹的设定，对吧？
We hadn't done it until we'd met Marshall's brothers and the idea of meeting a sibling of infin rounding out the world.
在见到马修的兄弟之前我们还没做过这个，而引入一个兄弟姐妹的概念能让世界观更加丰满。
This is a real rounding out the world episode.
这是一集真正让世界观变得丰满的剧集。
We liked meeting Robin's sister getting a peek into that seeing Robin as all of a sudden, this like very overprotective, seeing a new side of Robin, overprotective big sister.
我们喜欢看到罗宾的妹妹，得以一窥她的生活，看到罗宾突然变成了一个非常过度保护的、展现出罗宾新一面的过度保护的大姐姐。
And the idea that it sparks everyone having to kind of volunteer their story.
而且这个想法引发了每个人都不得不主动分享自己的故事。
That's actually a pretty good hymium form.
这其实是一个很好的《老爸老妈浪漫史》的套路。
We've done that a few times where people have to give up.
我们已经用过好几次这种大家不得不坦白秘密的桥段了。
Game night.
游戏之夜。
The game night was like that, I give up your embarrassing story, and I guess we were retreading that a little bit.
游戏之夜就是那样的，被迫说出你尴尬的故事，我想我们当时有点在重复那个套路。
But we liked that there was these stakes built in of what is Robin's sister going to do?
但我们喜欢其中内置的悬念，罗宾的妹妹会做什么？
Is she going to lose her?
她会失去贞操吗？
There's a good, like, you want to stay tuned to see what's going to happen there.
这是一个很好的点，你会想要继续看下去，看看接下来会发生什么。
And then the bigger question, because we don't really know who Robin's sister is, but you care.
然后是更大的问题，因为我们其实并不了解罗宾的妹妹是谁，但你在乎。
But Ted and Robin, and the I love you, Ted blurted, I love you on the first date, and Robin still has yet to say it once, we thought that was interesting.
还有泰德和罗宾，泰德在第一次约会时就脱口而出的“我爱你”，而罗宾至今还没有说过一次，我们觉得这很有趣。
That was a bigger chess move in this episode.
这是这集中更大的一步棋。
And I think without, I think we needed that.
而且我认为，没有这个可不行。
I remember feeling like we needed that because we're like, any show could do, here's a few funny virginity stories but what's happening in the present day.
我记得当时觉得我们需要这个，因为我们觉得，任何剧都可以做“这里有一些搞笑的初夜故事”，但当下正在发生什么才最重要。
It's almost like the virginity stories are the bottle episode.
这些初夜的故事几乎就像是一集封闭场景剧（bottle episode）。
Robyn saying, I love you is moving the chess piece forward.
罗宾说“我爱你”才是推动剧情发展的关键一步。
Is moving the chess piece forward?
是在推动剧情发展吗？
Yeah.
对。
And also getting that side of Ted, that his architect adorax side, he wants to go to the Empire State Building.
而且还能展现泰德的那一面，他那种建筑狂热的一面，他想去帝国大厦。
Was it the debut of Ted's quasi sexual fascination with the Empire State Building?
那是泰德对帝国大厦产生某种准性吸引的首次亮相吗？
his anthropomorphizing the Empire State Building to be his friend or girlfriend?
是他把帝国大厦拟人化成他的朋友或女朋友吗？
Yes.
是的。
This is the beginning of that.
这就是这一切的开始。
People still like, tell me Empire State Building Stories as if I have the thing.
大家到现在还像我真的拥有那座建筑一样，跟我讲“帝国大厦的故事”。
I have maybe other architectural things that movie, but not that one.
我可能对别的建筑有那种感觉，但绝对不是那个。
Although I can see it, we have a little balcony outside our bedroom, and I can see the Empire State Building from here.
虽然我能看到它，我们卧室外面有一个小阳台，从这儿能看到帝国大厦。
That's very funny.
太搞笑了。
I love you've become the spokesperson for a very specific fetish.
我喜欢你已经成了某种极其奇特恋物癖的代言人。
I'm the same, that's the only way I can get aroused either.
我也是，这也是我唯一能产生性冲动的方式。
No, no, that's not me.
不，不，那可不是我。
What's happening?
发生什么事了？
They're like furries, but they're like MPs.
他们就像福瑞控（furries），但他们是帝国大厦控（MPs）。
MPs.
帝国大厦控。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈尔德曼，《超级纠结》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接受听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：“我30岁了，但很害怕在纽约开车。”
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：“为什么我挂倒挡时不能调节车载音响的音量？”
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《超级纠结》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问HyperFixedPod.com收听。
Back to the show.
欢迎回到节目。
Where did falafel, which she says, instead of saying I love you, she says falafel.
法拉费（falafel）是哪里来的，她不说“我爱你”，而是说“法拉费”。
falafel, we already mentioned Rob Greenberg once at the refrigerator joke idea, writer, hilarious writer, Rob Greenberg, always used to talk about what are the funniest words to say.
法拉费，我们刚才已经提过一次罗布·格林伯格，就是冰箱笑话的主意提供者、编剧、超级搞笑的编剧罗布·格林伯格，他以前总是讨论说什么词最搞笑。
We knew we wanted Robin to have this kind of glitched and brain melt moment of not knowing, not being able to say I love you, but wanting to say something.
我们知道我们想让罗宾出现这种大脑短路和死机的时刻——不知道、说不出“我爱你”，但又想说点什么。
And Rob, for sure, pitched falafel, which really, also really made me laugh all that.
而罗布绝对推荐了“法拉费”，这真的也让我笑得不行。
It had forgotten that it was falafel.
我差点都忘了那是“法拉费”。
Rob always says the funniest words are falafel.
罗布总是说最搞笑的词就是“法拉费”。
It's all Middle Eastern food for him.
对他来说全都是中东食物。
It's all Middle Eastern foods.
全都是中东食物。
How do me?
胡姆斯（Hummus）怎么样？
It's probably in there.
可能也在里面吧。
And he's, yeah, I think he pitched falafel and it just broke us all for like a half.
而且他，对，我想他推荐了“法拉费”，然后直接把我们所有人都笑趴了大概半分钟。
Well, it also like, it has enough.
嗯，而且它也，它有足够的……
I love you.
我爱你。
I love you falafel.
我爱你法拉费。
It's so like, it's got your lips and teeth do similar things in your tongue.
它太像了，你的嘴唇和牙齿做出的动作以及舌头的位置都很相似。
So why is she saying there were falafel to him in that moment?
所以为什么她在那个时刻对他说“法拉费”？
What is Ted's reaction to that?
泰德对此有什么反应？
Why did she just say falafel to me?
她为什么刚刚对我说了“法拉费”？
Yeah.
对。
She having some sort of brain event?
她脑子出什么毛病了吗？
So Robin's sister is played by Lucy Hale, who now is an enormous star, right?
所以罗宾的妹妹是由露丝·海莉扮演的，她现在可是一位超级巨星了，对吧？
Huge star, yeah, this is before, right?
超级巨星，对，这是她成名之前，对吧？
Pretty little eyes, isn't that it?
《美少女的谎言》（Pretty Little Liars），是这个吧？
I think so.
我想是的。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
She was great.
她演得真棒。
Or maybe she had just started, God, I can't remember the timeline.
或者她可能刚开始拍，天哪，我记不清时间线了。
She was, she just started and so she was kind of like, already known and we put, yeah, so it's great to have her on there, she's great.
她当时，她才刚开始拍，所以她其实已经有点名气了，我们把——对，所以能请到她真的很棒，她太棒了。
Did she also, am I misremembering this?
她是不是也——我是不是记错了？
Did she also, was she on a like a Disney show with David Tedson?
她是不是也，她是不是和大卫·泰森演过什么迪士尼的节目？
Well, Selena Gomez was.
哦，赛琳娜·戈麦斯演过。
Oh, is that right?
哦，是吗？
It was on, like, Wizards of- Right, Wizards of Waverly Place.
是在那个，类似《少年魔法师》——对，《少年魔法师》里。
Yeah.
对。
I wonder, I might be misremembering that.
我在想，我可能记错了。
We seem so old right now.
我们现在看起来好老啊。
But, yeah, no, she was terrific.
不过，对，没错，她太棒了。
I mean, she was a kind of, also, like, Kobe kind of towered over her.
我是说，她有点像——而且，科比在身高上比她高出一大截。
And it was kind of like, you could really feel, I really liked seeing Kobe's maternal instinct come out.
那种感觉就是，你能真切地感受到，我真的很喜欢看到科比母性本能流露出来的那一面。
Yeah.
对。
And I think that was another idea of this episode, like just seeing that, oh, she has that side too.
我觉得这也是这一集的另一个立意，就是看到原来她也有那一面。
She's a big sister to somebody.
她是谁的大姐姐。
Yeah.
对。
There's also that thing of like, when you're 15, 16, 17, you think you're the oldest person that ever lived.
还有那种感觉，就是当你15、16、17岁的时候，你觉得自己是有史以来年纪最大的人。
Yeah.
对。
And then when you get older and you actually see 15, 16, 17, you're like, when you are a baby.
然后等你长大了，真正看到15、16、17岁的人时，你会觉得，天呐，这还是个婴儿。
It's a baby.
这就是个婴儿。
You're a baby.
你就是个婴儿。
I know.
我懂。
Yeah.
对。
I think about some stuff I did in high school that I'm like, who did I think?
我想起我在高中时做过的一些事，我就在想，我当时把自己当成什么人了？
What, like, what were we thinking?
什么，就，我们脑子里在想什么？
Like we were actually putting our lives in deep danger.
就我们当时其实是把自己的生命置于极度危险的境地。
You know?
你知道吗？
No, absolutely.
对，完全是。
We like, we shouldn't have been in charge of ourselves to the extent that we were, and we were so convinced that we were adults.
我们就像，我们根本不该由自己做主到那种程度，而我们当时还那么坚信自己已经是成年人了。
Yeah.
对。
And yeah, it's not an, it's six, it seemed very young.
而且，对，这不是一个——六，显得非常年轻。
It seemed very young, the age is discussed in this episode, and Lucy seemed very young.
这一集里讨论的年龄显得非常小，露西也显得非常小。
I don't know how old she really was, but yeah, you worried about her.
我不知道她当时到底多大，不过，对，你会为她担心。
There was something vulnerable, and like you wanted, I liked Robin for wanting to protect her.
有一种脆弱感，就你会希望，我喜欢罗宾想要保护她的那种心情。
In that way, even though Robin was being completely hypocritical compared to her own experience, which is hilarious.
以那种方式，尽管和罗宾自己的经历相比，她完全是在伪善，这太搞笑了吧。
Yeah.
对。
But I can report in that Lucy was on Wizards of Waverly Place, if that helps.
不过我可以汇报一下，如果这有帮助的话，露西确实演过《少年魔法师》。
Yeah, right.
对，没错。
Thank you.
谢谢。
No, you got it.
不客气，不用谢。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Who was Kyle?
凯尔是谁？
Okay, so this is what happens when I was watching this episode.
好吧，这就是我当时看这一集时的情景。
I thought, that kid's hilarious.
我想，这小孩太搞笑了。
He seems familiar.
他看起来好面熟。
Where do I know him from?
我从哪里见过他？
And do you know how I know him?
你知道我是怎么认出他的吗？
Because this is, I think, the deepest cut in joke in this episode.
因为这绝对是，我认为这一集里最晦涩难懂的内部梗。
So when Ted tells his kids, she went forward with, she had sex with Kyle, she got pregnant, she had quintuplets, and then her life, what she got, I don't know, it's just, I actually was like, did Stephen Lloyd write this joke?
所以当泰德告诉他的孩子们，她后来跟——她跟凯尔发生了性关系，然后怀孕了，生了五胞胎，接着她的人生，她得到了什么，我不知道，其实我当时就在想，难道是斯蒂芬·劳埃德写了这个笑话？
Like this is very dark, very dark.
就这个笑话非常黑暗，非常黑暗。
But I know that Ryan Pinkston, is his name.
但我知道那个演员叫瑞安·平克斯顿。
I know him because it was on the show, Quintuplets, that you and Carter wrote on, that I went to a taping of because my girlfriend at the time was in the show.
我知道他是因为有部剧叫《五胞胎》，你和卡特参与过编剧，我去过录制现场，因为我当时的女朋友在那部剧里。
I forgot that was a joke, but we didn't meet at that point.
我都忘了那是个笑话，不过我们当时还没见过面。
No, no, we didn't meet.
对，对，我们没见过面。
But I went to a taping and I remembered him from that show, but you make a quintuplets joke.
但我去过录制现场，我对他在那部剧里的表现有印象，结果你们居然写了一个《五胞胎》的笑话。
We do.
我们确实写了。
Which was, it had to have been only for the two of you.
这绝对是——肯定只有你们俩才懂吧。
It was for the no, no, it was revenge for several writers that had that.
不是为了——不，不，这是为了报复当时参与过那部剧的好几个编剧。
Oh, oh, there were a couple people in the room.
哦，哦，编剧室里有好几个人呢。
I had to do a very lengthy tour of duty.
我当时得服一段非常漫长的苦役。
I think the show quintuplets lasted one season, worked as many hours as nine seasons of Harry Potter in terms of the writer's room.
我觉得《五胞胎》这部剧只播了一季，但从编剧室的工作量来看，我们工作的小时数简直相当于九季《哈利·波特》。
And the quality spoke for itself.
而它的质量真是有口皆碑。
Hold for hold for hold for tears.
大家先停一下，准备好迎接眼泪。
Who else was on?
还有谁参演了？
Okay, so Stephen Lloyd, Gloria Kellner on Kellogg's who wrote this episode.
好吧，斯蒂芬·劳埃德，还有在凯洛格公司的格洛丽亚·凯尔纳，他们写了这一集。
Okay, Chris Harris, I think briefly was imprisoned in the quintel plates writer's room too.
好吧，克里斯·哈里斯，我觉得他当时也曾短暂地被“囚禁”在《五胞胎》的编剧室里。
It was and Carter and I were the briefest of all of them.
确实，我和卡特是所有人里面呆的时间最短的。
We finagled our way.
我们想方设法钻了空子。
We had all signed deals with 20th at around the same time, all of those writers.
当时我们那些编剧差不多在同一时间都和二十世纪福克斯签了合约。
And Carter and I, like, we smelled trouble right away being on the show.
而我和卡特，一进那个剧组就立刻嗅到了危险的气息。
We were just like put on there to write one script, but we weren't like full-time writers on there, and it was still TBD where we were gonna be put.
我们当时的感觉就是，把我们弄去写一个剧本，但我们并不是那里的全职编剧，而且我们最终会被安排到哪里还未定。
And we got our agent to beg us out.
于是我们让经纪人求情把我们弄了出来。
And I think we called the studio to be said, we cannot be on this.
我想我们还给制片厂打电话说，我们绝对不能留在剧组。
And by the way, I want to hit pause.
顺便说一句，我想按一下暂停。
I love Andy Richter.
我超爱安迪·里查德。
Ryan Pinkston was great.
瑞安·平克斯顿演得真好。
It was really, he was great in this episode.
真的，他在这一集里表现得很棒。
And there was a lot of talented people.
而且里面有很多才华横溢的人。
It was just seven days a week to write a kind of up-the-metal family show that none of the writers were thought excited about.
只是一周七天都在忙着写那种拼凑出来的家庭情景喜剧，没有一个编剧对它感到兴奋。
It was just like one of those.
它就是那种类型的剧。
And we, Carter and I basically started carving our Shawshank tunnel out of that writer's room like very early, and we got out of there somehow miraculously, and these other writers got stuck there for like the full season.
然后我们，我和卡特基本上很早就开始在那个编剧室里像《肖申克的救赎》那样凿地道了，我们不知怎么地奇迹般地逃了出来，而其他那些编剧却被困在那里干了整整一季。
But didn't you also have an episode go like get taped?
不过你们是不是也有一集剧本被拍成播出了？
We did.
对啊。
We shot that.
我们拍了那一集。
We wrote the second episode of Quintelblis, but not to brag.
我们写了《五胞胎》的第二集，虽然不是为了炫耀。
But I think that Carter, I remember telling me like, it was actually quite exciting to be on set when an episode with words you were written.
但我记得卡特曾对我说过，当片场拍摄的是写有你们台词的剧本时，其实是相当令人兴奋的。
It's the only other multi-camera sitcom credit Carter and I had or still have.
那是卡特和我曾经拥有、或者至今仍拥有的仅有的另一个多机位情景喜剧署名。
We've written some single camera and some animated and some this and that, but we have not, that's our entire multi-camera resume before him yet.
我们写过一些单机位喜剧、一些动画片，还有这样那样的东西，但我们还没有——那是截至目前我们所有的多机位履历。
But this is like the deepest, this is such a deep-cut Hollywood comedy thing of like that Ryan is playing Kyle.
但这简直是，这是好莱坞喜剧里最晦涩、最资深的梗，就是瑞安在扮演凯尔。
You have a quintuplets joke.
你们居然还藏了一个《五胞胎》的笑话。
Like that just was like for like a handful of people.
这感觉就像是专门写给寥寥几个人看的。
It was for, I mean, it works on its own.
它是——我是说，它本身也能独立成立。
It's like it's the idea for having quintuplets from like one pregnancy is like it fits a bit of like this incredibly unrealistically terrible, you know, it's future Ted scaring his kids straight, right?
就像，一次怀孕生下五胞胎这个设定，就有点符合那种极其不切实际的糟糕情况，你知道的，这就是未来的泰德在吓唬他的孩子们，让他们走正道，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
But the fact that it lined up to also be a quintuplets reference when half of the writers of a famished mother had just slightly traumatizing.
但它恰好也是一个《五胞胎》的梗，而当时那个剧组的一半编剧刚刚经历过一段稍微有点创伤的经历。
Yeah.
对。
sort of Shawshank like time in there and we got out and we said to ourselves when we got out Carter and I was like I remember when we left that writer's room it was already clear it was going to be not very fun in there and we when we left we felt like we were in it was a scene in the war movie where like we're going home back to the States but our brothers in arms are still stuck in a shit you know and we thought to ourselves if we can possibly like send back for these writers we're gonna go build a new life but we're not going to forget about you guys.
我们在那儿度过了一段有点像《肖申克的救赎》的日子，等我们出来的时候，卡特和我都对自己说——我记得当我们离开那个编剧室时，里面已经很清楚地表明待在那儿不会有什么乐趣了——当我们离开时，感觉就像身处一部战争电影里，就像我们要回家回美国去，但我们的战友仍然被困在水深火热之中，你知道的，我们当时想，如果我们能尽可能把这些编剧接应出来，我们要去建立新生活，但我们不会忘记你们这些家伙的。
And it's true.
千真万确。
We, I mean, they're some of our dear friends.
我的意思是，我们，他们是我们最亲爱的朋友。
So we, we later, the quintuplets, I think, was long since canceled.
所以我们，我们后来——《五胞胎》我想早就被砍了。
We didn't rescue them from that.
我们并不是从那个节目里把他们拯救出来的。
But we, I'm really trashing quintuplets more than I mean to hear, by the way, by the way.
不过我们，顺便说一下，我其实并不是故意要把《五胞胎》贬得一文不值。
But we got, we got all of those writers on to have it from other.
但我们把所有那些编剧都弄来做《老爸老妈浪漫史》了，从别的……
Yeah.
对。
Eventually, that's why that reference is so crazy.
最终，这就是为什么那个梗会这么疯狂。
And Ryan.
还有瑞安。
Well, I mean, the part Ryan piece in plays is really funny.
嗯，我的意思是，瑞安参演的部分真的很有趣。
It's not that big, but it's really.
戏份虽然不多，但真的很棒。
He knew, he knew the mission.
他懂，他懂这个任务。
he understood the mission.
他真的理解这个任务。
He really does.
他确实很懂。
He's also hot all the time.
而且他一直都很性感。
Looks like hotness runs in the family.
看来性感是他们家的家族传统。
And I loved Colby.
我很喜欢寇碧。
Oh, you say things.
哦，你可真会说话。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
You said the way Colby played that was so funny to scandalize kind of prudish.
你刚才说寇碧演那个角色的方式太搞笑了，那种大惊小怪、假正经的感觉。
Oh, oh, my stars kind of.
哦，我的天哪，那种感觉。
Yeah.
对。
I like that.
我很喜欢那个。
It is so funny.
真的太搞笑了。
The the it's almost like code switching, right?
这几乎就像是语言切换，对吧？
Like you're you're like a cool person who hangs out in a bar and has sex when you want it.
就像你是一个在酒吧混、想什么时候发生性关系就什么时候发生性关系的酷盖。
It's like you're your younger sister.
而这就好像是你的小妹妹。
You become And I also have the subtext of it too that she, Kobe, that she, Robin, had, you know, grew up too fast, right?
你变成了……而且其中还有一层潜台词，那就是她，寇碧——她，罗宾——你知道的，成长得太快了，对吧？
She was Robin Sparkles.
她曾是“罗宾闪亮登场”。
It's very interesting to me to, I was trying to do the math and I didn't even know myself like, where does this virginity with the gay boyfriend, where does that fall in the Robin Sparkles timeline?
对我来说非常有趣的是，我曾试图理清时间线，但我自己甚至都不知道：这个“和同性恋男友发生性关系”的贞操梗，在“罗宾闪亮登场”的时间线里到底排在什么位置？
Is she Robin Sparkles during that?
那时候她是“罗宾闪亮登场”吗？
Is Robin Sparkles after that?
还是说“罗宾闪亮登场”在那之后？
We conveniently didn't say it and I don't know that I have an answer, but I did that she wants to protect her younger sister because she was Robin didn't feel, you know, protected as this child star and had a series.
我们很巧妙地没有说出来，我也不知道自己有没有答案，但我知道她想要保护自己的小妹妹，因为罗宾作为这个童星并没有感觉到，你知道的，受到保护，而且经历了一连串的事。
And we saw we see later in series that she had an obsession with James Vanderbeek, not actually James Vanderbeek, his character Simon, the very funny episode.
我们看到，我们在剧集后面的部分看到她对詹姆斯·范德比克有过迷恋，其实不是詹姆斯·范德比克，而是他的角色西蒙，那一集非常搞笑。
We see that she had she has some scars.
我们看到她身上有一些创伤。
So she wants to protect her younger sister, which I love.
所以她想要保护她的小妹妹，我真的很喜欢这一点。
I love that.
我太喜欢了。
Kobe also really made me laugh when she's complete she's day drinking and they're like You had whatever, you know, before you're three p.m.
寇碧有一场戏也把我逗笑了，当时她完全……她在白天喝酒，然后他们说：“你不管怎样，你知道的，下午三点前就……”
And it's like, that's why I need your help.
然后她说：“这就是为什么我需要你的帮助。”
That's why I need your help.
“这就是为什么我需要你的帮助。”
So funny.
太搞笑了。
Little throw away drunk lines on how I met your mother are often so funny.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》里那些一闪而过、关于喝醉酒的台词往往都超级搞笑。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah, I need to see some penguins like right now.
对啊，我现在就想看几只企鹅。
Oh, yeah, it's my favorite time one.
哦，对，这是我最喜欢的时刻之一。
Yeah.
对。
I was just going to say, I didn't, in addition to forgetting the quintuplets joke entirely and being delighted by that.
我正要说呢，除了完全忘记了《五胞胎》那个梗并为此感到惊喜之外。
And I made a note too that we had to talk about that.
我还做了一个笔记，说我们必须聊聊那个。
I'm so thrilled that you also caught and remember that because if you're super weird trajectory, like that was maybe the first time we're in the same room together.
我太高兴了你也注意到了并还记得，因为按照那种超级奇怪的发展轨迹，那可能就是我们第一次在同一个房间里。
The sound stage of our quintuplets was shot.
我们拍摄《五胞胎》的那个片场。
100%.
100%。
百分之百。百分之百。
It's probably the first time you, me, and Carter were without knowing it in a room together.
那大概是你、我和卡特在不知情的情况下第一次共处一室。
Yeah.
对。
It's really weird.
真的很诡异。
It is weird.
确实很诡异。
Super weird.
超级诡异。
I forgot about that and was delighted by it.
我都把这事儿给忘了，不过看到它还是觉得很开心。
I forgot about just what a big role of the movie Dirty Dancing plays in this episode.
我差点忘了电影《辣身舞》在这集里占了多大的分量。
Whoa, wait.
哇，等等。
There is so much dirty dancing in this episode.
这一集里有超级多的《辣身舞》。
I'm so pretty dancing.
我太喜欢《辣身舞》了。
But I have a question.
不过我有个问题。
How did you get that footage?
你们是怎么搞到那些镜头版权的？
Was it a 20th movie?
那是二十世纪福斯电影公司的片子吗？
I can't remember.
我记不清了。
Alec, when you look if it's a 20th movie because I mean, the answer is we paid a fucking lot of money for the footage.
亚历克，你查查看这是不是福斯的电影，因为我的意思是，答案是我们花了他妈的一大笔钱才买下这些镜头。
But once we had that idea of just really spending a lot on cutting Barney in there beautifully, and I think the special effects hold a really great time.
但一旦我们有了那个想法，就是花大价钱把巴尼天衣无缝地剪进去，而且我觉得特效在当时真的很棒。
I thought it was amazing.
我觉得太惊艳了。
I remember leaving for the day when I remember Neil as Swayze in front of a green screen.
我还记得那天要下班的时候，我记得尼尔站在绿幕前扮演斯韦兹。
Like I was walking out and I think I saw.
就像我正要走出去，然后我想我看到了……
You're like, how is this our job?
你当时就像在说：“这怎么能是我们的工作？”
How is this some, I'm leaving work now as the Swayze sequence begins?
“这怎么能是……当斯韦兹的片段开始时，我居然要下班回家了？”
It's really funny.
真的太搞笑了。
it looks great.
效果看起来棒极了。
I mean, I would be, I can't remember how much we paid for the music, that song, time of your life, at the end of the episode, the weepy song.
我的意思是，我当时会……我不记得我们为那首歌付了多少版权费，就是插曲结尾时那首催泪的歌《Time of Your Life》。
I was like, did we spend half a million dollars on frickin' music in this episode?
我当时想：我们是不是在这集的该死的音乐上花掉了五十万美元？
And then the licensing the footage, it must have been, this episode must have deceptively cost a lot to make.
再加上镜头授权费，这一集的制作成本在表面之下肯定高得惊人。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I would imagine.
我可以想象。
I forgot what it was, but it was a lot.
我记不清具体是多少了，但绝对是个大数字。
I loved Marshall stay away from drugs except for pot.
我超喜欢马修说的“远离毒品，大麻除外”。
Yeah, and a little wink.
对，还有一个小小的眨眼。
A little wink.
一个小小的眨眼。
It's really nice.
真的很棒。
There's a kind of like, there's like everyone, how we met your mother's like, they party, but like pretty wholesomely.
这里有一种……就像每个人在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里那样，他们会开派对，但感觉非常健康向上。
They do, yeah.
确实，对。
No one's doing cocaine.
没有人吸可卡因。
It's just like it's drinking a locational pot.
就只是喝喝酒，偶尔抽抽大麻。
They sneak some cigarettes, like it's very kind of post-collegiate New York partying.
他们会偷偷抽几根烟，非常像是大学毕业后那种纽约式的派对。
It is, and like adults like late 20s partying.
确实是，就像成年人、快三十岁的人办的那种派对。
Yeah, totally.
对，完全是。
I also like this.
我也很喜欢这个。
The Marshall and Lily debate is the other thing that got this episode going.
马修和莉莉的辩论是这一集的另一个主线。
Like, I remember we were in this area of everyone's story, but we needed something in the present.
就像，我记得我们当时处于每个人故事的这个阶段，但我们需要一个当下的切入点。
And the idea that Lily's story, Robin's story, triggers this debate about Lily's story, triggers this thing for Marshall of wait, was I not was I not Neil Armstrong?
莉莉的故事、罗宾的故事引发了关于莉莉过去的一场辩论，而这又为马修触发了一种心态：等等，难道我不是……难道我不是尼尔·阿姆斯特朗吗？
Was I not What is my entire definition of myself changed by this one little piece of information?
难道我不是……我对自己所有的认知，难道都被这一个小小的历史信息给改变了吗？
And also the juiciness of that debate, it reminded me of the debate of like, should couples go to the bathroom in front of each other, like from Zip-Zip-Zip.
而且那场辩论的趣味性，让我想起了那种辩论，比如情侣应不应该在对方面前上厕所，就像那个“Zip-Zip-Zip”里的情节。
This idea of like, well, is it losing your virginity if it's just that little, if it's just the lobby?
这种想法就是，呃，如果只是那一点点，如果只是在大厅里，那算不算是失去童贞？
And once we had that, it lined up solo at the Empire State Building and the lobby versus the top of the building.
一旦我们有了这个，它就排成了一条单行线，帝国大厦的大厅对阵大厦的顶端。
Once we knew we had that metaphor, it was like, that was the universe smiling on us like It's also another example of like Marshall and Lily, especially I would even say Marshall more than Lily are really invested in the story of Marshall and Lily.
一旦我们知道我们有了这个隐喻，就好像，那是命运在向我们微笑，这也像是马歇尔和莉莉的另一个例子，特别是，我甚至可以说马歇尔比莉莉更投入于马歇尔和莉莉的故事中。
Like the iconography, the mythology of Marshall and Lily, what that represents and how inspiring they are to other people.
就像标志性的符号、马歇尔和莉莉的神话色彩，这代表着什么，以及他们对其他人是多么地具有鼓舞作用。
They really are.
他们真的是这样。
Really?
真的吗？
As if everyone in line at the Empire State Building is like, of course, you know, Marshall and Lily.
就好像帝国大厦排队的每个人都觉得，当然，你知道的，马歇尔和莉莉。
There was a couple that lost the opportunity to go to David.
有一对情侣失去了去戴维那里的机会。
They have the same one at college.
他们在大学里也有同样的经历。
Adam and Eve likes himself important as a couple.
亚当和夏娃觉得自己作为情侣很重要。
People rely on us.
人们依赖我们。
The entire Judeo-Christian tradition is based on us.
整个犹太-基督教传统都是建立在我们的基础上的。
Yes, and if this falls, society itself can't keep going.
是的，如果这个倒塌了，社会本身就无法继续下去了。
It's a little crumbles.
它有点崩溃了。
Yeah, and it was great also the checkmate moment of Marshall saying the lobby doesn't count.
是的，而且马歇尔说大厅不算，那一刻的将军（checkmate）也非常棒。
I remember that was a great way, a very efficient way to pay off the end of their story.
我记得那是一个很棒的方式，非常高效地为他们故事的结局做了个收尾。
And the idea, the idea too of how we edit our own story is like that's another thing I like, his future Ted is always editing his stories for his kids.
而且这种想法，关于我们如何编辑自己的故事的想法也是，这是我喜欢的另一件事，他的未来泰德总是在为他的孩子们编辑他的故事。
and sometimes just like lying to them for the quintuplets bit here.
有时候甚至只是为了这里的五胞胎梗而对他们撒谎。
But the idea of like self-editing your own stories, Barney is self-mythologizing, his virginity loss to cover up something actually very painful in this episode.
但这种自我编辑自己故事的想法，巴尼在自我神话化，他失去了童贞来掩盖这一集中实际上非常痛苦的事情。
And Marshall and Lily both agree in the end, the story's better if it doesn't count.
而马歇尔和莉莉最后都同意，如果这不算数，故事会更好。
It's we lost our virginity to each other.
是我们把初夜给了彼此。
That's what we're going with.
这就是我们的定论。
And just the idea that like, the way we frame our own stories to ourselves, it matters.
仅仅是这种想法，我们对自己讲述自己故事的方式，这很重要。
It matters for our mental health.
这对我们的心理健康很重要。
It matters for our self-definition, and they even give Barney that gift at the end of letting him have it.
这对于我们的自我定义很重要，他们甚至在最后把这个礼物送给了巴尼，让他拥有了这个说法。
A true and honest recounting is almost impossible because memory is always doing its tricks and edits and backflips and self-justifications and all that stuff, right?
一个真实而诚实的叙述几乎是不可能的，因为记忆总是在玩弄把戏、进行编辑、后空翻、自我辩解以及所有这些东西，对吧？
It's like, yeah.
就像是，对。
It's very, so all we really have is our perspective on things, or sometimes I told a story so much that I'm like, well, the story is what the memory is.
这非常，所以我们真正拥有的只是我们对事情的看法，或者有时我把一个故事讲了太多遍，以至于我觉得，好吧，记忆就是这个故事。
It doesn't even matter what really happened because it's like, it's become a separate thing.
甚至不在乎真正发生了什么，因为它就像，它已经变成了一个独立的东西。
It's taken on a life of its own.
它有了自己的生命。
Yeah, and you don't know all the facts, either it's a time like, if someone, if before we started recording today's podcast, you said, someone said to me, what's the first time we were in a room together with Josh Radner?
是的，而且你并不知道所有的事实，有时候就像，如果在我们今天开始录制播客之前，你对我说，有人对我说，我们第一次和乔什·拉德纳在同一个房间里是什么时候？
I'd be like in Ocean Park.
我会觉得是在海洋公园。
And when he came in to Carter in my development office in audition, I was like, no, we were in the same room together shooting the fucking quintuplets episode.
当他来到卡特和我的开发办公室试镜时，我会说，不对，我们在同一个房间里是在拍那个该死的五胞胎那一集。
Like there's just like weird revisions.
就像总有一些奇怪的修改。
It's like, well, no, that's not gonna count.
就像，哦不，那个不算。
It's the first time I was in a room with Josh is when he auditioned.
我和乔什第一次共处一室是在他试镜的时候。
That's a better story.
那是更好的故事。
And on the end of Ted's virginity story too is really great.
而且泰德的初夜故事的结局也很棒。
The Ted knows to add to reverse the roles in his virginity story to help talk Robin's sister.
泰德知道在自己的初夜故事中反转角色，来帮助开导罗宾的妹妹。
Well, that's literally what I've said from day one is that part of the power and comedy of how he made it mother, it's a gender flip.
好吧，这正是我从第一天起就说过的话，那就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的力量和喜剧效果的一部分，它是一个性别翻转。
So Marshall and Ted are these like emotionally open and vulnerable and they love relationships and their sentimental kind of quote unquote feminine qualities where the women are these, like, tougher, more unsetimental, you know, guns and cigars in Robin's case.
所以马歇尔和泰德这些人在情感上是开放和脆弱的，他们热爱人情关系，他们有感性的、所谓的女性特质，而女性则是那种更强硬、更不感性的人，你知道的，在罗宾的例子里就是枪支和雪茄。
And fireworks, Mexican fireworks in the forest.
还有烟花，森林里的墨西哥烟花。
And with Ted's high school girlfriend.
还有泰德的高中女朋友。
Yeah.
对。
And then Barney was always this kind of parody of hyper masculinity.
然后巴尼一直是一种过度男性化的讽刺。
Yeah.
对。
You know?
你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
So I that's a perfect example of it.
所以我认为这是一个完美的例子。
It's like it's it's just a flip.
这就好像，这只是一次反转。
I do remember she was very funny, by the way, Ted.
顺便说一句，我确实记得她非常有趣，泰德。
She was funny.
她很有趣。
You guys were both funny in the mirror roles of those scenes.
你们俩在那些场景的反向角色中都很有趣。
Like Ted being a deck at first, it was like, that doesn't seem like Ted.
比如泰德一开始像个混蛋，这看起来不太像泰德。
I loved, it was almost like Ted Mosby architect, like I love getting to play with Ted's face.
我喜欢，这几乎就像建筑师泰德·莫斯比，我喜欢尝试扮演泰德的另一面。
I love getting to play something unexpected like that.
我喜欢尝试一些意想不到的角色。
That was always really fun.
那一直真的很有趣。
Yeah, that was a good flop.
是的，那是一个很好的反转。
It made me laugh when Barney said, I'll pay you $10,000 for that diary.
当巴尼说“我出一万美元买那本日记”时，把我逗笑了。
For Robin's high school diary.
为了罗宾的高中日记。
Maybe that was such, yeah, that was one of my favorite, like I forgot about it.
也许那是这样的，是的，那是我最喜欢的之一，就像我都忘了。
Yeah.
对。
And then when when she's describing all the things her and Kyle has done, Marshall says even Kyle gets to do that.
然后当她描述她和凯尔做过的所有事情时，马歇尔说连凯尔都能做那种事。
Even Kyle gets to do that.
连凯尔都能做那种事。
Oh my God.
哦我的天哪。
The old married couple.
老夫老妻。
So tech flag.
技术标志（Tech flag）。
Do you know what I'm going to say?
你知道我要说什么吗？
Like outdated tech.
就像过时的技术。
What's the thing Jenna and Angela say?
珍娜和安吉拉说什么来着？
Like they say like old tech or old tech or yeah, I think something like that.
就像他们说老科技或老科技之类的，对，我想是这样的。
They had a phrase for a crap.
他们对废话有一个短语。
I forgot gold tech.
我忘了，黄金科技。
Okay.
好吧。
When what was the old tech?
那时候老科技是什么？
and Katie says, I already put it up on my Myspace.
凯蒂说，我己经把它发到我的MySpace上了。
My Myspace, I called it out.
我的MySpace，我提到了。
I said Myspace, modular, there it is.
我说MySpace，模块化的，就是这样。
My space, Robin Sparkles also was on Myspace when we launched it.
我的空间，我们推出时罗宾·斯帕克斯也在MySpace上。
You know what I liked getting to?
你知道我喜欢接触到什么吗？
This is the top bunk bottom bunk joke.
这是上铺下铺的笑话。
This is the great thing about a long running show.
这就是长期播客的伟大之处。
You can say we said this joke in the pilot, you know, Marshall when the bottom bunk moves, the top bunk moves too, it's just physics.
你可以说我们在试播集中就说过这个笑话，你知道的，马歇尔说当下铺动的时候，上铺也跟着动，这只是物理现象。
The idea that a season and a half later, you get to like see that joke.
这种在播了一季半之后，还能看到那个笑话的想法。
That's again, filling in the mythology.
这再次充实了神话。
And I really, I really love that.
我真的很喜欢，真的很喜欢。
It just, it rewards somebody that remembers that from the first episode of the series, but it stands on its own.
这只是，它奖励了那些从剧集第一集就记住这一点的人，但它本身也能独立成立。
If you don't remember that, and it's hilarious to act out.
如果你不记得那个，演出来也是超级搞笑。
And the idea, oh my God, Marshall is saying, I let you my Walkman.
还有那个想法，哦天哪，马歇尔说，我把我的随身听借给你了。
But I let you my Walkman.
但我把我的随身听借给你了。
So Ted could listen to cassette tapes, I guess, while they fucked underneath him.
所以泰德可以听磁带，我猜，当他们在他的下方做爱时。
He's like, I can't get it.
他就像是，我受不了了。
It's a bed rattled.
床都在摇晃。
Yeah.
对。
I let you listen to the Proclaimers while we did it.
我在你们干的时候让你们听The Proclaimers乐队的歌。
I loved, I remember getting to do that.
我喜欢，我记得当时演了那一幕。
And it was, it's funny because I liked the way I did, would I, I said please don't, is that what I said?
而且，这很有趣，因为我喜欢我当时的表现，我会说“请不要”，我是这么说的吗？
Oh my God, and you all curled up between like a little, curled up.
哦天哪，然后你们都蜷缩得像个小不点一样，蜷缩着。
You were like, you were amazing.
你当时就，你太棒了。
You were like traumatizing, trying to swaddle myself.
你当时简直像受了创伤一样，拼命想把自己裹起来。
You were swaddled, you were so swaddled.
你被裹起来了，裹得严严实实的。
It was, you're a little head peeking at me, just a head.
就是，你的小脑袋瓜探出来看着我，就只有个头。
But what I like about it is it's essentially like the joke, like it's not a theater joke.
但我喜欢的是，这本质上就像个笑话，它不是那种剧场里的笑话。
You need the camera cut for that joke.
那个笑话需要镜头切换。
To like truly land.
才能真正达到效果。
Yes, that is a cut wide, yeah.
对，那是一个远景切换，没错。
to cut wide.
切换到远景。
Yeah, exactly.
对，没毛病。
It is a full.
这是一个完整的。
Yes.
对。
It was a thing of beauty getting to put that together.
把它剪辑到一起真是一件美好的事。
That was great.
那太棒了。
Yeah.
对啊。
So then, um, yeah, the, the dirty dancing footage I really think is like an extraordinary thing.
所以然后，嗯，对，那个，《辣身舞》的素材我真的觉得是个了不起的东西。
Yeah.
对。
And, uh, what is it?
而且，呃，那是怎么回事？
Is it Marshall who says damn you, Swayze, like, cause he couldn't get she's like the wind.
是马歇尔说“该死，斯威兹”吗？就因为他搞不到那首《她是风》。
Yeah.
对。
And it's back again.
然后它又回来了。
And, uh, okay.
然后，嗯，好吧。
And who I, I, this also felt like a Stephen Lloyd joke when, uh, what What does Ted say to the guy who says, thank you, man, I was going up there to jump.
还有谁，我，这感觉也像是个斯蒂芬·劳埃德的笑话，当，呃，泰德对那个说“谢谢你，伙计，我本来打算去那上面跳楼”的家伙说了什么？
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
Yeah.
对。
What does he say to him?
他对那个人说了什么？
Like, Ted is saying, see, I say, I love you.
就像，泰德在说，看吧，我说，我爱你。
I love you.
我爱你。
And he says, I love you to the guy that was in simple.
然后他对那个在单身派对上的人说。
I love you.
我爱你。
It was the benevolence of the universe.
那是宇宙的仁慈。
It was the most simple.
那是极其简单纯粹的。
And the very, the very thing that Ted, uh, that he thought ruined his life in the pilot ends up saving learning.
而泰德，呃，他在试播集中认为毁了自己生活的那件事，最终却拯救了……学习。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I love you.
我爱你。
Wait too soon.
等等，太早了吧。
That is even sooner than you blur the cheruban.
这比你脱口而出小天使还要早。
You'll know that guy once.
你总会认识那种人的。
That guy needed it.
那个人当时正需要这个。
That guy.
那个人。
God bless Ted Mosby, that may have been a Steven Lloyd.
上帝保佑泰德·莫斯比，这可能真的是斯蒂芬·劳埃德的手笔。
It feels like a Steven Lloyd too.
这听起来也很像斯蒂芬·劳埃德的风格。
Steven Lloyd is a genius writer.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德是个天才编剧。
All nine seasons, very much a mother, just about.
整整九季，简直就是个大功臣，差不多就是这样。
And the dark jokes are often, often, Steven's.
而且那些黑暗的笑话通常，往往都是斯蒂芬想出来的。
But Ted saved her life there, my God.
但泰德在那里救了她一命，天哪。
I know.
我知道。
This is an eventful present day episode.
这是一个充满了大事件的现代戏份。
So you need stuff in the present.
所以现代部分也得有点内容。
Like, people's lives being safe.
比如，别人的生命被挽救了。
Yeah.
对。
Well, it's also like, it's a sweet thing where you, You know, on our show, there were literal background actors, right?
嗯，这也是一种，挺温馨的事，你懂的，在我们的剧中，真的有背景演员，对吧？
But in our lives, like I sort of think about this, like if I'm having dinner with my wife somewhere, like we're the protagonists of the dinner, like we're the main, we're the series regulars, right?
但在我们的生活中，我大概会这么想，如果我和我妻子在某个地方吃晚餐，我们就是晚餐的主角，我们是常驻演员，对吧？
Of the dinner and the life and people are background.
晚餐和生活的主角，而其他人都是背景。
But also like, I think we've talked about this, but there's that definition in that book, dictionary of obscure sorrows that, Sonder, did we talk about that, Sonder?
而且，我想我们讨论过这个，在那本书《晦涩忧伤词典》里有一个定义，叫“Sonder（路人感知）”，我们讨论过那个吗，Sonder？
Yeah, I think so.
对，我想是的。
Yeah, the realization that everyone you pass on the street in the traffic, every single person has an incredibly, as rich an interior life as you.
对，那种意识到你在街上、在车流中擦肩而过的每一个人，他们每个人都有着和你一样极其丰富的心灵世界。
And as heartbreaking and dimensional a life as you do.
有着和你一样令人心碎且立体的生活。
And I think it's funny when you, especially in New York City, when you're kind of bumping into people like bill your balls or whatever, just to be like, to see this guy like, he was going up there to throw himself off the building and a couple kind words from the gang and he's he's not going to you know and again it's also it's another it's more evidence of the sweetness and benevolence of the how I met your mother universe right that you can save a life without even knowing it or meaning to because there's goodness this gang brings goodness into to the universe in the house.
我觉得很有趣的是，当你，特别是在纽约市，当你和比尔·你的球或者类似的人擦肩而过时，看到这个家伙——他本打算上楼去把自己从大楼上扔下去，而这群人几句温暖的话就让他打消了念头，你知道的，而且这也是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》宇宙的甜蜜和仁慈的又一个证据，对吧？你甚至不用知道或没有那个意图就能拯救一条生命，因为这种善良，这群人为这个宇宙、为这座房子带来了善良。
Yeah.
对。
And this old man.
还有这个老头。
He musted me, fell in love with you, knew where you were sitting.
他照顾了我，爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now commercials.
现在是广告时间。
End of commercials?
广告结束了？
Back to show.
回到节目。
By the way, we're also learning that line with the 200 rights holders over the life of dirty dancing.
顺便说一句，我们还了解到在《辣身舞》的整个版权期内，有200个版权所有者。
It was Lionsgate that owned during this time.
当时拥有版权的是狮门影业。
Okay.
好吧。
Yeah.
对。
I think we paid out.
我想我们为此支付了。
of money for that and the music.
一大笔钱，还有音乐版权。
That was a, I'm so glad we did.
那真是一个，我太高兴我们这么做了。
I freaking love that we did that sequence in this episode.
我太喜欢我们在这一集里加入那个桥段了。
And then it ends the episode.
然后它为这一集做了结尾。
It comes back around at the end.
到了最后又呼应上了。
So it's very sweet how Ted is the one who kind of saves the day with Katie.
所以泰德用凯蒂扭转乾坤，这感觉非常温馨。
Yeah.
对。
I really like that too.
我也真的很喜欢那个。
You know, but I do.
你知道，但我是。
By lying.
通过撒谎。
Yeah, sure.
对，没错。
But we are rearranging of the facts.
但我们是重新编排了事实。
Exactly.
没错。
what he did.
他做的事。
Well, again, it's almost like the Chris Harris joke of the art teacher, right?
嗯，再说一次，这有点像克里斯·哈里斯关于美术老师的笑话，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
All the same words.
用的都是同样的词。
Yeah.
对。
See it again.
再看一遍。
It's all the same words.
用的都是同样的词。
Yeah.
对。
All the same words.
用的都是同样的词。
It's a very kind of reliant, like a very trusted kind of how I make your mother a bit.
这是一种非常靠谱的、非常标志性的《老爸老妈浪漫史》式的梗。
Like that.
就像那样。
Yeah.
对。
And it was right.
而且确实如此。
He was a dick.
他是个混蛋。
He was going.
他当时正要去。
He was Ryan.
他是瑞安。
I mean, it was a character.
我的意思是，那是个角色。
He was a dick.
他是个混蛋。
They rescued her from a jerk.
他们把她从一个混蛋手中救了出来。
So exactly.
所以完全正确。
Another good thing happened there.
那里还发生了另一件好事。
So I just want to go back to the end of the episode that when they asked Barney, like, what was the real virginity, losing your virginity story?
所以我想回到那一集的结尾，当时他们问巴尼，真正的童贞，也就是失去童贞的故事到底是什么？
Yeah.
对。
And he starts listing movie plots.
然后他开始列举电影情节。
Yeah.
对。
So he lists, what are the, what are the movies to this?
所以他列举了，这些都是什么电影？
Fast times are written on high.
《开放的美国学府》。
Risky business.
《乖仔也疯狂》。
War games.
《战争游戏》。
War games is my favorite.
《战争游戏》是我的最爱。
There's not even a sex scene in that one.
那里面甚至连一场床戏都没有。
But again, these are like gen X touch don't movies.
但话说回来，这些就像是X世代的标志性电影。
Like this is like, fast times, war games, risky business, fast times, war games, dirty dancing.
就像是，比如《开放的美国学府》、《战争游戏》、《乖仔也疯狂》、《开放的美国学府》、《战争游戏》、《辣身舞》。
Dirty dancing.
《辣身舞》。
It's like iconic music.
就像标志性的音乐。
It's like 80s movies.
就像是80年代的电影。
What percentage of people in their 20s watching it now?
现在看这部剧的20多岁的人里有多少比例知道？
I know, but the gang, this is like their cultural ephemera, is that the word?
我知道，但这帮人，这就是他们的文化随笔，是这个词吗？
Like this is their lexicon.
就像这是他们的词汇库。
Like they absolutely would know he's describing these movie plots.
就像他们绝对会知道他在描述这些电影情节。
And then when they get to the actual story, He was 24, it was his mom's friend.
然后当他们说到真实的故事时，他24岁，那是他妈妈的朋友。
She kept calling him Barry.
她一直叫他巴里。
We also act this out later in series.
我们在剧集的后面也演过这一幕。
This is like a bunk bed type, it's like we see that, we see this on this later.
这就像是双层床那种，就像我们看到的，我们在后面见过了。
And then his sheet smelled like cigarettes for, menthols, menthols, menthols.
然后他的床单有烟味，薄荷味的，薄荷味的，薄荷味的。
And the thing that I thought was so, like.
我觉得最……的那种事。
And he was old.
而且他当时很老。
Yeah, he's 24.
对，他24岁。
He was like 23 or something.
他大概23岁什么的。
Yeah, the thing that was so sweet and so like good friend, is like they know that Barney dwells happier in like delusion land.
对，最贴心、最像好朋友的一点是，他们知道巴尼在妄想世界里过得更快乐。
Like he is happier in fantasy land and they give it to him.
就像他在幻想世界里更快乐，而他们成全了他。
And they're happier too.
而且他们也更快乐。
They're happier too.
他们也更快乐。
Like his actual story is too crushingly depressing.
就像他真实的故事太令人心碎、太压抑了。
So sad to bring into the booth.
拿到录音室里说太令人难过了。
So they're like, tell us again, you know.
所以他们就说，再给我们讲一遍，你知道的。
Tell us about Kellerman's.
给我们讲讲凯勒曼度假村的事。
Did anyone put baby in the corner?
有人把贝比角落里了吗？
God no.
天哪，才不。
That was one of my very list.
那是我的愿望清单上的头几项之一。
Now, didn't anybody ever put baby in the corner?
话说，难道从来没有人把“宝贝”关在角落里吗？
It's such a weird question.
这是一个好奇怪的问题。
It's such a sweet, like crazy way to take care of your friend.
这真是一种贴心又疯狂的方式来照顾你的朋友。
It is, it's sweet.
确实，很贴心。
It's very sweet.
非常贴心。
And reminds you that Barney is, it's all smoke and mirrors.
这提醒了你，巴尼其实……全都是虚幻的表象。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Covering up a lot of old wounds.
在掩盖许多过去的伤痛。
I was trying to do the math as with Robin Sparkles.
我刚才在试着理清罗宾·斯帕克尔斯的逻辑时间线。
And again, we left it conveniently big.
而且再说一次，我们故意把时间留得很模糊。
Does weird is like Barney as a hippie and Shannon and all that stuff?
那怪异的部分像是嬉皮士时期的巴尼、香农以及那些事呢？
Where is that?
那是在哪里？
Well, that all falls after.
噢，那些都在后面。
So that's mid 20s, that's years after college, or like, I think we did, I think we did say that Shannon never, they never had sex.
所以那是二十岁出头，那是大学毕业好几年之后，或者，我觉得我们说过香农从来没有，他们从来没有发生过性关系。
Maybe it was supposed to be before and it was a college or just post college.
也许本来设定是在那之前，是大学期间或是刚毕业后。
And she kept him stringing him along with then ended up having sex with other guys.
而她一直吊着他，结果最后却跟别的男人发生了关系。
So maybe it all does that up.
所以也许这些时间线是能对上的。
I'll ask our student listeners to let me know if what we did on our own show.
我会让我们的听众留言告诉我，我们在自己的剧里到底是怎么设定的。
It's probably not a thread you need to pull.
这大概不是一条你需要去深究的线索。
It's, you know, I'll come collapsing down.
因为，你知道的，整条线会土崩瓦解。
I don't know why I'm pulling it.
我不知道我为什么非要扯出来。
to admit it, that every now and again, I'm not sure how much.
我得承认，时不时地，我也不太确定到底有多少。
But it also adds up, you know, it's pure comedy.
但这也说得通，你知道，这纯粹是喜剧。
It's hilarious, but it also was like Barney's been hanging with these people enough and long enough, and they've been hanging with him enough that he does say, like he starts revealing more of himself, you know, even though he's like, he slams it shut.
太搞笑了，但同时也让人觉得，巴尼和这些人混在一起的时间够久、也够深了，他们陪他的时间也足够让他表露心迹，你知道的，尽管他马上又把心门“啪”地关上了。
They all slam it shut.
他们全都把门关上了。
Yeah, but they learned something about him there that they didn't know, that helps explain him.
对，但他们在那时了解到了关于他的一些他们以前不知道的事，这有助于解释他这个人。
And he actually, I really like Neil played that actually very heavy of heart that moment where he, Okay, here's what it really was.
而且实际上，我真的很喜欢尼尔在那一幕里演得非常沉重，当他说，“好吧，真相其实是这样的。”
And he looks really wounded as he reveals that.
当他揭露这一点时，他看起来真的很受伤。
But then he looks like a plant that gets watered when he gets to go back into fantasy.
但接着，当他回到幻想中时，他又看起来像一株得到浇灌的植物。
I really, I do think one of Neil's comedic superpowers is the quickness with which he can hit the turns.
我真的觉得，尼尔的喜剧超能力之一就是他转换情绪的速度极快。
Like the, there's gonna be a baby that moment, you know, in there with Wayne.
就像那个“会有一个小婴儿”的时刻，你知道的，和韦恩在一起的时候。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
He's just so deft at those.
他处理这些转换实在是太娴熟了。
Like it's incredible.
简直不可思议。
So, that feels like we covered it, is there anything else that's kicking around Craig for that episode?
所以，感觉我们聊得差不多了，克雷格，关于那一集还有什么其他津津乐道的地方吗？
It was a fun one.
那一集很有趣。
It was a really fun one.
真的是非常有趣的一集。
I like it.
我很喜欢。
I really like these ones where we get to know everybody better.
我真的很喜欢这种能让我们更深入了解所有人的剧集。
It's not all set in the present and yet the stakes of we're meeting a sister, we're moving, it was the relationship of Ted and Robin is moving somewhere forward.
它并不完全设定在现在，然而，我们要见一个妹妹、我们要搬家，泰德和罗宾的关系正在朝着某个方向前进，这些都是很有分量的。
Marshall and Lily have a kind of mini-crisis, but I love, I love filling in the lore.
马歇尔和莉莉遇到了一种迷你危机，但我真的很喜欢补充这些背景设定。
I think it's a great way to put it.
我觉得这样说太贴切了。
It also feels like a kind of debut of more of Ted's like fun facts like trivia Ted like yeah, you know, yeah, also, you know, also like they never get to the top of the Empire State Building.
这也感觉像是泰德更多“冷知识”设定的首次登场，比如爱博学的泰德——对啊，你知道的，还有，他们从来没有登上帝国大厦的顶楼。
I mean, we have it.
我是说，我们有这个桥段。
There's a little bit of waiting for Godot or Godot, however we properly say it, Alec.
这里有点像是《等待戈多》（Waiting for Godot or Godot），无论我们怎么正确发音，亚历克。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Theater people say it's Godot, right?
戏剧界的人都念 Godot，对吧？
With like the New Year's Eve episode where they never get to up the party, you know, or the Empire State Building episode where they never get to the top of the Empire State Building, There's kind of this mini lesson in there that the you know the journey is more important than a destination Like we we actually enact that in The series and that is all you know in some ways the point of the series as well You know the the thing of like if Seinfeld were happening today Like you know that that runner like someone does a twitter account.
就像他们永远去不了那个派对的跨年夜那一集（你知道的），或者他们永远到不了帝国大厦顶楼的帝国大厦那一集，里面其实藏着一个小小的教训，那就是“过程比目的地更重要”。我们在剧里确实演绎了这一点，在某种程度上这也是整部剧的意义所在，你知道的，就像“如果《宋飞正传》发生在今天”那种梗，有人专门搞了个推特账号。
I think of like I know I actually was cast in one It was really funny like But they just imagine if Seinfeld was happening today and they kind of use modern things you know, you know, Kramer gets in a Twitter fight with so-and-so, you know, stuff that wasn't going on then.
我想起……我知道我其实参演过一个，真的挺搞笑的，就好像他们想象如果《宋飞正传》发生在今天会怎样，他们会加入一些现代元素，你知道的，比如克莱默跟某某在推特上开撕，你知道的，这些是当时没有的事。
And I have this thing because, you know, they discontinued making pennies, the U.S. Treasury.
而且我一直觉得，因为你知道的，美国财政部他们停产了一分硬币。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Which head would be so upset?
那泰德会有多抓狂？
There's a part of me that wants to know how Ted would respond to the discontinuation of the penny.
我心里有个声音很想知道泰德会怎么回应停产一分硬币这件事。
I feel like he would gather the gang together for, like, he put together a little side show on the history of the penny, and he'd do, like, a little funeral, like a eulogy.
我觉得他会把大家聚在一起，比如，他会搞一个关于一分硬币历史的小型科普秀，然后他会办一场小葬礼，就像是一场悼词。
for the penny.
为了一分硬币。
Yeah, I think you're right, a little penny eulogy.
对，我觉得你说得对，一个一分硬币的微型悼词。
That's such a great, see, I love hearing that from you because I saw that story and I didn't immediately think of that.
这太棒了，你看，我很高兴从你口中听到这个，因为我看到了那篇报道，但我没有立刻想到这些。
It just occurred to me now.
我刚刚才想到。
I didn't even think about it.
我甚至都没想过。
It just occurred to me right now.
我刚刚才想到的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
But I love that that shows that like how the actor who plays Ted, there's something, like you feel that.
但我很喜欢这一点，它表明了饰演泰德的演员那种感觉，有些东西，你是能感同身受的。
Like that just, you actually just felt that.
就像那个，你刚才真的有这种感觉。
Like I wish I knew what this character would say about that.
就像我希望我知道这个角色会对此说些什么。
But I think we just, that's it.
但我觉得我们刚刚想到的，就是这样。
That's what he would do.
这就是他会做的事。
He would have a little, he would call together a small funeral, a tasteful funeral for the penny.
他会举办一个小型的，他会号召大家办一场小型葬礼，为一分硬币办一场有品味的葬礼。
But of course, he already would have had his daughter named Penny at this point in the timeline, wasn't he?
但当然啦，按这个时间线发展，这会儿他的女儿不就已经叫彭妮（Penny）了吗？
Speaking of which, is there anything we wanted to talk about?
话又说回来，有什么事是我们想聊聊的吗？
I was just going to ask why we haven't been recording in a couple of weeks.
我本来正想问为什么我们已经好几周没录音了。
Oh, I guess we buried the lead.
哦，我想我们把最重要的消息放后面了。
We could talk about it.
我们可以聊聊这个。
Sure.
当然。
I had my wife and I had a son.
我和我太太迎来了我们的儿子。
we had a baby human.
我们迎来了人类幼崽。
And it's been about three and a half weeks.
已经过去大约三个半星期了。
It'll be a month in a couple of days.
再过几天就满一个月了。
And we're just delighted and exhausted.
我们既欣喜又筋疲力尽。
Oh man, we're so happy for you.
天哪，我们真为你高兴。
We're so happy for you.
我们太为你高兴了。
And you're a hero to be here doing a podcast with a teen little baby in the other room.
而且你能顶着隔壁房间的小不点婴儿来这里做播客，你简直是个英雄。
That is amazing.
太了不起了。
So we have received a number of messages, people saying, I'm loving season two of the the podcast, but I really miss questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother, who also happens to be married to Josh.
所以我们收到了不少留言，人们说：“我超喜欢第二季播客，但我真的好想念一个从来没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的临床心理学家的提问和观察，而她碰巧还是乔什的妻子。”
Where is that segment?
那个环节去哪了？
That segment is feeding a small child.
那个环节正在喂养一个小孩。
Now you know the answer, yes.
现在你知道答案了，是的。
I've seen that question a lot from fans of the show, and first of all, props are drawn out from a huge outside impact, because her little contributions were very missed.
我经常从剧迷那里看到这个问题，首先，必须要向她致敬，因为她的那些小小的贡献真的让人非常想念。
but now we get to say why, and it's the best reason possible.
但现在我们终于可以说明原因了，而且这是最好不过的原因。
Yeah, so maybe, I don't know, she'll come back with the frequency that she, but I hope if she's inspired, she'll drop one in an episode.
对，所以也许，我不知道，她可能会以她以前那样的频率回归，但我希望如果她有灵感的话，她会在某集里客串一下。
I miss it, I miss it, but this is it.
我很想念，真的很想念，但情况就是这样。
Well, I get her questions and observations because I sit there and watch the show with her, so I'm still getting them.
嗯，我能听到她的提问和观察，因为我坐在那儿和她一起看剧，所以我还是能听到。
It's just you guys aren't, but maybe one day.
只是你们听不到了，但也许有一天会吧。
No pressure, Jordana, she doesn't just like to be pressured.
没有压力，乔丹娜，她不喜欢被施加压力。
Yeah, just got bigger, bigger things going on.
对，只是手头有更重要、更忙的事情。
But we're so happy for you, Josh.
但我们太为你高兴了，乔什。
Well, thank you, thank you for the time off.
好吧，谢谢，谢谢你们给我的假期。
It was necessary.
这是很有必要的。
We needed a break.
我们需要休息一下。
Yeah, I mean, no one will have known that.
对，我是说，没有人会察觉到。
The episodes will have all dropped in order, but we banged out a whole bunch of them, knowing what was coming, and we took a little break, and this is the first one back after.
这些剧集会按顺序全部上线，但我们在知道即将发生什么的情况下，一口气赶录了好多集，然后我们休息了一小会儿，这是回归后的第一集。
So it's very exciting.
所以这非常令人兴奋。
It was the exact, we got to the exact midpoint of season two, and this starts off the second half, this first time in New York.
我们刚好到了第二季的正中间，而这一集是下半季的开端，也就是第一次来到纽约。
So it was very, very symmetrical.
所以非常非常的对称。
My son already has great timing.
我儿子已经有很棒的时间感了。
Great timing, just like his dad.
时间感极佳，就像他爸爸一样。
And it's the best.
这真是太棒了。
We're very happy for you.
我们为你感到非常高兴。
Well, thanks.
谢谢。
And just in live time, Jordana has just thanked us all right now for saying this to her right now in our text messages.
就在实时连线中，乔丹娜刚刚在我们的短信里向我们所有人表达了感谢，因为我们刚才对她说了这些。
Oh, I did see it.
哦，我看到了。
You're welcome.
不客气。
You're alive.
你还活着。
But also, I asked if, I thought this was really funny.
不过还有，我问过——我觉得这个真的很好笑。
I asked if Jordana and my son could listen in on the episode, and Craig really made me laugh.
我问乔丹娜和我儿子能不能旁听这一期节目，克雷格真的把我逗笑了。
because he said I think it's high time we see how our pod plays in the advertiser coveted zero to one month old demo.
因为他说，我觉得是时候看看我们的播客在广告商垂涎的“零到一个月大”收听群体中的反响如何了。
Everyone's trying to get that audience.
每个人都想争取那个受众群体。
We need to know those smartless guys huge with those huge was zero to one month.
我们需要知道那些《聪明笨蛋》（SmartLess）的家伙们在零到一个月的群体里是不是超级火。
We got to see if we can do it.
我们得看看我们能不能做到。
Amazing.
太绝了。
Well this was like a little take your son to work day almost.
好吧，这几乎就像是个“带儿子上班日”。
They're in the other room and they're listening on.
他们就在隔壁房间收听着呢。
So yeah, so much love to you all.
所以，是的，向你们所有人送去满满的爱。
Oh, amazing, amazing, amazing, amazing.
哦，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了！
Yeah, thank you so much.
好的，非常感谢。
All right, when we are back with a segment that we like to call general questions, general questions.
好了，接下来我们要进入一个我们喜欢称之为“常规问题”的环节——常规问题。
That wasn't bad.
学得还不错。
That was dead on.
模仿得惟妙惟肖。
Can't you just think them?
你难道就不能直接致谢他们吗？
I absolutely can, but I have not done that.
我绝对可以，但我还没这么做。
I feel that because we always talk about how much it sucks.
我觉得是因为我们总是抱怨它有多糟糕。
And then you leave it in its sucky state to I do need to tell the world that my best friend of 40 plus years now at our recent dinner, Craig did claim ownership.
然后你却任由它保持那种糟糕的状态——我必须向全世界宣布，我和克雷格相识四十多年的最好朋友，在最近的一次晚餐上，克雷格竟然声称那是他的原创。
It was very awkward.
当时气氛非常尴尬。
Yeah.
对。
Over the salute.
关于那个敬礼。
I know.
我知道。
I went to elementary school and high school on college with him.
我和他一起上过小学、高中和大学。
So he was in college saluting like an idiot with all of us.
所以他在大学里和我们所有人一样，像个傻子一样在敬礼。
Yeah.
对。
And over dinner, he just casually said, I think that was mine.
而在晚餐时，他随口就说：“我觉得那是我的点子。”
And you've seemed very confident that was not true.
而你当时显得非常确信事实并非如此。
It's so childish and stupid.
这太幼稚、太愚蠢了。
It really feels like it had to be comfort, had to come for me.
感觉这绝对是、绝对应该是我想出来的。
I always felt like it was from you, but of course, it predated me meeting you guys in college.
我一直觉得那是你的点子，但当然，那发生在我上大学认识你们之前。
And I inherited it from you and I put it on the show.
我是从你那儿继承过来的，然后我把它用到了剧里。
I think I did.
我想我是这样的。
We asked her to hand that it was one of the few things I did ask for permission to do.
我们曾向她征求过同意，那是为数不多我请求许可才能做的事情之一。
Usually I don't tell people I'm putting something on the show and then they hate me.
通常我不会告诉别人我要把什么东西放进剧里，然后他们就会恨我。
This one I think you and also you guys just liked it.
但这个点子，我想你——而且你们大家也都挺喜欢的。
But you guys had a moment at dinner where it was like, no, no, it's very much like this episode, first time in New York, the sort of revisionist history of what we want to believe.
但你们在晚饭时有过这样一个时刻，就是，不，不，这非常像这一集，第一次去纽约，我们想要相信的那种修正主义历史。
Which I thought Joel Caves pretty quickly, like maybe he seemed like, maybe that was that one.
我觉得乔尔·凯夫斯很快就想到了，也许他觉得，也许这就是那个。
But he didn't claim it.
但他没认领。
He did claim it.
他确实认领了。
He didn't claim it.
他没认领。
He doesn't have a podcast though, so fuck that.
不过他没有播客，所以管他的。
Okay, so just a lovely note here from at Cosmonauts, I don't have a question this week, but I have to say, this is my favorite episode of TV of all time.
好吧，这里有一条来自“at Cosmonauts”的可爱留言，我这周没有问题，但我必须说，这是我历来最喜欢的电视剧集。
I like Ted, I'm a huge Empire State building nerd, and I love telling everyone my fun facts when I visit there.
我喜欢特德，我是个狂热的帝国大厦迷，每次去那里我都喜欢跟每个人分享我的趣事。
Also, I'm like Robin that I struggle confronting things like saying I love you.
另外，我和罗宾一样，很难去面对一些事情，比如对别人说我爱你。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Mm-hmm is my autistic special interest.
“嗯哼”是我的自闭症特殊兴趣。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
And this particular episode is when I rewatch at least once a week.
而这一集是我每周至少重温一次的剧集。
This episode is my number one source of comfort in my life and gives me the feeling of being in New York with my favorite characters, despite being a British teenage girl.
这一集是我生活中头号的慰藉来源，尽管我是一个英国女 teenager（青少年），它却给了我一种和最喜欢的角色一起在纽约的感觉。
This episode is everything to me and thank you Josh and Kobe for bringing these particular relatable characters to the screen.
这一集对我的意义重大，感谢乔什和科比把这些特别有共鸣的角色搬上银幕。
Oh, that's an amazing message.
噢，这是一条很棒的留言。
Boy.
天哪。
that.
真是这样。
I'm so glad that that meant that.
我很高兴它能有这样的意义。
What was her name?
她叫什么名字？
Do we say at cosmonauts?
我们刚才是不是说是 at cosmonauts？
Okay.
好吧。
Well, at cosmonauts, we're very excited.
好吧，at cosmonauts，我们非常激动。
The Brits sure name their kids differently.
英国人给孩子起名字真是不一样。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
Thank you for sharing that.
谢谢你分享这些。
I'm so glad the episode means that to you, Josh, again, like when we make these things and you put the message in the bottle and you throw it out into the ocean, you know, you can never know it's going to find at cosmonauts in England.
我很高兴这一集对你来说有这样的意义，乔什，就像我们制作这些内容时，你把漂流瓶扔进大海一样，你知道，你永远无法预知它会在英国被 at cosmonauts 找到。
When you're doing 22 to 24 a season, you don't have time to think about the ripple of the thing.
当你们一季要做22到24集时，你们根本没时间去考虑它带来的连锁反应。
You're just trying to complete the order.
你们只是在努力完成订单。
But this is the gift.
但这就是礼物。
That's why I said the messages are the best part, because this is it coming back to us, and it's just a glorious thing.
所以我才说这些留言是最好的部分，因为这就是它回馈给我们的东西，这真是一件美妙的事。
I also find Craig, I noticed this thing because I wrote and directed and starred in two movies, which is an insane thing to do in a lot of ways.
我也发现，克雷格，我注意到了这件事，因为我自编自导并主演了两部电影，在很多方面这都是一件疯狂的事情。
One of the reasons I liked it was because it was so overwhelming and it required so much of me that I couldn't spend too long deliberating and ruminating over things, but I just had to shoot from the hip instinct and I actually made some great calls just instinctually and I think you and Carter, on some level, it was too overwhelming to let your brain do alone.
我喜欢它的原因之一是，它太让人应接不暇了，需要我付出巨大的精力，以至于我没有太多时间去深思熟虑和反思各种事情，我只能凭直觉临场发挥，事实上我确实凭直觉做出了一些非常棒的决定，我觉得你和卡特，在某种程度上，事情繁重到不让你们的大脑独自运转。
So you guys probably, that's why there are a lot of patterns and things that were almost It's more like from a Jungian unconscious that fans pick up on, that you guys were probably operating on a different level because you just didn't have that much time to think about it from like whatever that you either love or write.
所以你们俩可能，这就是为什么会有很多模式和一些几乎更像是来自荣格无意识层面的东西，粉丝们能察觉到，你们当时可能在不同的层面上运作，因为你们根本没有那么多时间去从无论你热爱还是撰写的角度去思考它。
And it was all instinct.
而且一切全凭直觉。
I mean, we learned a lot from writing that one episode of quintuplets, but like not everything.
我的意思是，我们在写《五胞胎》那一集时学到了很多，但也不是全部。
I mean, that was the roadmap, but you know, there was a few times you know how they say in comedy, you should punch up.
我的意思是，那是路线图，但你知道，有好几次，你知道喜剧里怎么说的吗，你应该往高处发挥。
Yeah.
是啊。
You're really punching down.
你这简直是在往下踩。
You know what, this is like, all right, no more quintuplets.
你知道吗，就像是，好了，再也不写《五胞胎》了。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
I'm cutting you off.
我要打断你了。
It's so bad.
太糟糕了。
All these wonderful writers were on it.
所有这些优秀的编剧都参与其中。
We got some good things out of that show.
我们从那部剧里得到了不少好东西。
It was such long hours that everyone still carries their baggage that was in that writer's room of just the long hours.
当时的工作时间太长了，以至于每个人至今还带着那个编剧室留下的精神负担，也就是那些漫长的工作时间。
Anyway, this question is more from me.
不管怎样，这个问题更多是关于我自己的。
Craig, how do I put this?
克雷格，我该怎么说呢？
Ted loses his virginity to a girl named Molly.
特德和一个叫莫莉的女孩失去了童贞。
As you know, my first time...
如你所知，我的第一次……
Are we going here?
我们要聊这个吗？
I've talked to her this morning.
我今天早上和她聊过。
I've been given permission.
我已经得到批准了。
My first time was with a woman, a girl named Molly, on August 18th, which is your birthday.
我的第一次是和一个女人，一个叫莫莉的女孩在一起，在8月18日，也就是你的生日那天。
So every time it's my birthday, one of the first texts text, I got a smell like going, happy me losing my virginity day.
所以每次到我生日的时候，我收到的第一条短信之一，闻起来就像是在说，祝贺我失去童贞日快乐。
Wow.
哇。
And I'm like, you just ruined my birthday again.
然后我就想，你又把我的生日给毁了。
Every year, my question is legitimately.
每年我的问题其实都是。
Well, I mean, for my Molly, I would have told you at the time, I think it might just be in one of these weird fucking coincidences.
好吧，我是说，对于我的那个莫莉，我当时可能会告诉你，我觉得这可能只是那些该死的巧合之一。
Why wouldn't I?
我为什么不呢？
No, I think I would have, um, I can't.
不，我想我会的，嗯，我不能。
I got a, I got, I wish we had Gloria on or somebody like, I don't remember.
我得，我得，我希望我们能把格洛丽亚或什么人请来，我不记得了。
I mean, maybe, maybe I was giving you a little shout out.
我是说，也许，也许我当时是在给你一个小小的致意。
Like Josh just said, it was all a blur.
就像乔什刚才说的，当时一切都很模糊。
you're bringing out of instinct, you're grabbing things from life, or maybe I did it unconsciously, but I don't remember thinking, oh, Alec, we'll see this, and it will mess with his brain.
你是凭直觉创作的，你从生活中抓取素材，也许我是在无意识中这么做的，但我不记得当时想过，“哦，亚历克会看到这个，这会把他的脑子弄糊涂。”
I wish I could say that, and that you ruin my breast every year with us, but.
我希望我能这么说，而且你每年都用这个来毁我的胸……不对，生日。
Yeah.
是啊。
All right.
好吧。
So, Dell Osseilosu, who is writing to us from the great, how we made your mother Facebook fan group, which everyone should join, sense.
那么，德尔·奥塞洛苏（Dell Osseilosu），他在我们伟大的“老爸老妈浪漫史”Facebook粉丝群里给我们留言，每个人都应该加入，有道理。
I've never been to New York.
我从来没去过纽约。
It's on my bucket list.
它在我的愿望清单上。
It's been since I was a kid.
从我还是个孩子的时候起就是这样。
I thought that's where the famous people live.
我以为那是名人们居住的地方。
I wanted to visit Carrie Fisher in her apartment there because I read so much.
我想去那里拜访凯莉·费雪的公寓，因为我读过很多关于她的书。
I love that.
我太喜欢这个了。
By the way, I would have loved that too.
顺便说一句，我也会很喜欢那样的。
Yeah.
是啊。
That sounds amazing.
听起来太棒了。
What are three things you'd like the world to know about the city?
关于这座城市，你想让世界知道的三件事是什么？
What would you recommend?
你有什么推荐的吗？
Good question.
好问题。
You know, I went to NYU for grad school.
你知道，我在纽约大学读研究生。
And to me, New York for years was just like I just felt comfortable below 14th Street.
对我来说，多年来纽约给我的感觉就是，在14街以南让我觉得很舒适。
I felt like downtown New York was my New York.
我觉得纽约市中心就是我的纽约。
But now my wife, when we met, she introduced me to this incredible neighborhood in Brooklyn where we live now.
但现在我的妻子，我们相遇时，她把我带到了布鲁克林的一个不可思议的街区，我们现在就住在那里。
And I got to say like, if you come to New York, don't sleep on Brooklyn.
我必须说，如果你来纽约，千万不要忽略布鲁克林。
Brooklyn had some of the best restaurants, some of the best parks, and my parents were just here, meeting their grandson for the first time, and they had such a funny breakfast at this.
布鲁克林有一些最棒的餐厅，一些最棒的公园，我的父母刚刚来这里，第一次见他们的孙子，他们在一个地方度过了一个非常有趣的早餐。
Do you guys know juniors on Flatbush?
你们知道夫拉特布什（Flatbush）的朱尼尔（Junior's）餐厅吗？
It's like famous cheesecake.
那里以芝士蛋糕闻名。
I sent them there because they were staying nearby.
我让他们去那儿，因为他们就住在附近。
Oh, yes.
哦，知道。
And they just had this hilarious time with, they made friends, they made all the tables, we're all kind of talking to each other.
他们在那儿度过了一段非常欢乐的时光，他们交了朋友，所有桌子的人都在互相聊天。
And if you look, sometimes I think New York, like Manhattan can feel a little bit like, okay, yeah, this is the center of capitalism and this is where the UN is and this is where Broadway is and it can feel shiny and big and exciting.
如果你仔细看，有时候我觉得纽约，曼哈顿可能会让人觉得有点像，好吧，是的，这就是资本主义的中心，联合国在这里，百老汇也在这里，它可能会显得光鲜亮丽、宏大而令人兴奋。
But Brooklyn and you could say Queens, like any of these other boroughs, they feel like more like, this is where people live.
但布鲁克林，你也可以说皇后区，就像其他任何这些行政区一样，它们更让人感觉，这里才是人们生活的地方。
This is where people send their kids to school.
这里是人们送孩子上学的地方。
This is where people, not that people don't grow up in Manhattan, my wife did, and Alec, you did, right?
这里是人们——并不是说曼哈顿没有人成长，我妻子就在那儿长大的，亚历克，你也是，对吧？
I did, yeah.
我是，是的。
Yeah, so, but there's something about, I've just been delighted how much I love living in Brooklyn.
对，所以，但总有一种感觉，我一直为自己多么喜欢住在布鲁克林而感到高兴。
So just shout out to Brooklyn.
所以向布鲁克林致敬。
I would yes, end of that and say that my wife is from Park Slope.
我会的，顺便说一句，我妻子来自帕克坡。
So I, in college, I spent a ton of time there with her.
所以在大学里，我和她在那儿度过了大量的时间。
We got married in Prospect Park.
我们在展望公园结的婚。
Wow.
哇。
People don't know.
人们可能不知道。
Prospect Park is beautiful, it's created by, it's by the people who brought you Central Park.
展望公园很美，它是中央公园的设计者建造的。
Old said, right?
老奥姆斯特德，对吧？
If you like Central Park, yeah.
如果你喜欢中央公园的话，对。
But Old said, apparently thought that Prospect Park was the crown jewel, like he thought that was the better part.
但老奥姆斯特德显然认为展望公园是皇冠上的明珠，他觉得那是更好的部分。
I think that that was his preferred achievement.
我认为那是他最得意的成就。
And it's beautiful, definitely go, yeah, go check that out if you're here too.
它真的很美，如果你在这里，一定要去看看。
If you have a dog or a baby.
如果你有狗或者宝宝的话。
Yes.
对。
Prospect Park.
展望公园。
You've now got both, so you can speak from experience.
你现在两样都有了，所以你可以凭经验说话。
And my choice, I would actually say, is Central Park, I did grow up in Manhattan, but I have a specific recommendation for folks, which is get there early, get there nice and early.
而我的选择，我其实会说是中央公园，我确实在曼哈顿长大，但我对大家有一个具体的建议，那就是早点去，早早地去。
Start on the corner, start on 59th and 5th.
从那个拐角开始，从第59街和第5大道开始。
and don't take a map, just start walking.
不要拿地图，直接开始走。
And if you just head north, you can walk for hours and hours and you'll just find one hidden gem after another without making any plans.
如果你一直往北走，你可以走上几个小时，不需要做任何计划，就能接连发现一个又一个隐藏的宝藏。
You'll get all your meals there.
你可以在那里解决所有的饭。
You'll find something for the kids.
你会找到适合孩子的东西。
You'll find something for everyone.
你会找到适合每个人的东西。
I do that and when I go to New York now, I tend to just walk from one corner to the other.
我现在去纽约时也会这么做，我往往只是从一个街角走到另一个街角。
Yeah, that would be my thing to just walk.
对，这就是我的习惯，到处走走。
Just walk.
就只是走路。
And neighborhoods change every 10 to 12 blocks, you'll feel like, oh, just the character of the neighborhood.
每隔10到12条街区，街区就会发生变化，你会感受到那种不同的特色。
And one other park related thing, every summer I try to see at least one of the Shakespeare and the park productions at the Delacorte and they just reopened the Delacorte after a huge renovation.
还有一件与公园有关的事，每年夏天我都尽量去德拉科特剧院看至少一场莎士比亚公园戏剧演出，他们刚刚经过大规模翻修重新开放了德拉科特剧院。
There's something about seeing Shakespeare in Central Park as the sun is setting that is like such a like great New York thing to do.
在夕阳西下时在中央公园看莎士比亚戏剧，真是一件非常有纽约特色的棒极了的事情。
Like it really, we saw 12th night recently, which was so wonderful.
真的，我们最近看了《第十二夜》，太精彩了。
Like, it's just so much fun to be in New York.
在纽约真的太有趣了。
And you feel like you feel the culture, you feel the landscape, you feel the buzz and the excitement, the arts.
你能感受到文化，感受到风景，感受到那种热闹、兴奋和艺术气息。
And like, it's just wonderful.
而且，这简直太棒了。
So go see Shakespeare in the park.
所以一定要去看公园里的莎士比亚戏剧。
I think we'll have announced this by then too.
我想我们到时也会宣布这个消息。
And maybe I won't say the date yet, but there's going to be another How I Met Your Mother fundraiser theme concert in June.
也许我还不宣布具体日期，但在6月份将会有另一场《老爸老妈的浪漫史》慈善主题音乐会。
If you're here in June, look for that.
如果你六月在这里，留意一下。
How much mother bar the bar that McGee's that McLarens is based on is McGee's on 55th Street.
老爸老妈里麦克拉伦酒吧的原型麦吉酒吧，就在55街的麦吉酒吧。
Those are two good himmium things you could do.
这是你可以去做的两件跟老爸老妈相关的好事。
But yeah, I just just walk.
不过说真的，就到处走走吧。
I live down and try back and I just I walk my dog along the water every day and it's just like see the Statue of Liberty every single day.
我住在翠贝卡附近，我每天都沿着水边遛狗，每天都能看到自由女神像。
You know how you can do like the sex in the city and the friends walking tours of New York?
你知道大家怎么搞像《欲望都市》和《老友记》那样的纽约徒步之旅吗？
Is there one for how I met your mother?
有没有《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的这种导览？
I think that I'm not sure.
我觉得，我不确定。
That's a great question.
这是个好问题。
You know what?
你知道吗？
Hey listeners, let us know if you know what there is.
嘿，听众们，如果你们知道的话请告诉我们。
I know that himmium stuff is part of other TV tours.
我知道老爸老妈的元素是其他电视之旅的一部分。
Like there's some TV tour that like I think is its own bus or something and takes people they they stop at like the soup Nazi spot if that I'm not sure if that's still open or not but and then at McGee's I think McGee's is like one of the stops of like this tour and they go into how I met your mother bar on 55th there so I know that at least that part of it is incorporated in some other bigger tour.
比如有什么电视观光团，我想有他们自己的巴士什么的，载着游客在“纳粹汤老板”那儿停一下——我不确定那家店现在还开没开——然后去麦吉酒吧，我想麦吉酒吧是这类观光团的其中一站，他们会去55街那个老爸老妈的酒吧，所以我知道至少那一部分被纳入了一些更大的旅行团中。
All right we've got a nice letter to round this out for the for the episode job.
好了，我们有一封很棒的信来为这一集做个圆满的收尾。
All right yeah so here is this week's letter and if you would like to write us a letter that maybe we'll read on the air or drop us a voice note about what how I met your mother means to you or any other how I met your mother related beautiful things you'd like to share with us.
好的，没错，这是本周的信件，如果你想给我们写信，我们可能会在节目中朗读，或者给我们发一段语音，讲讲《老爸老妈的浪漫史》对你意味着什么，或者任何你想与我们分享的关于该剧的美好事物。
We always love receiving them.
我们总是很乐意收到这些。
Go to how we made your mother dot com h w m y m h w m y m w m y m w m y m w m y m dot com.
访问 how I met your mother 点 com，即 hwmym.com。
Go to contact and just follow the instructions there and tell us things.
点击联系我们，然后按照那里的指示告诉我们你的故事。
So here's this week's letter.
所以这是本周的信。
Hi, Josh and Craig.
嗨，乔什和克雷格。
I've watched him.
我看过这部剧。
So many times I've come to think of it as a best friend, a pillar I can turn to throughout my life for laughs, joy, comfort, understanding, and a shoulder to lean on.
看过太多次了，我开始把它当成我最好的朋友，是我一生中在遇到欢笑、快乐、安慰、理解以及需要一个可以依靠的肩膀时可以求助的支柱。
Whenever I talk with my sister, my actual best friend and soulmate in many ways, about a hard time either one of us is going through, I frequently relate the situation to him yum.
每当我跟我姐姐——她实际上是我最好的朋友，在许多方面也是我的灵魂伴侣——谈论我们俩正在经历的艰难时期时，我经常会把这种情况跟老爸老妈联系起来。
I'll say things like, it's like when Marshall and Lily got in that fight, or remember when Ted thought this was the greatest tragedy?
我会说类似这样的话：“这就像马歇尔和莉莉大吵一架的那次”，或者“还记得泰德认为那是最大的悲剧的时候吗？”
It's a timeless show that I will always go back to simply because it's given me so many answers in my life, even when the answer was, there is no answer.
这是一部永恒的剧集，我总是会重温它，仅仅因为它给了我生活中那么多的答案，哪怕当时的答案是：根本没有答案。
I love that.
我太喜欢这样了。
Sometimes I'll be feeling an intense emotion and pick a specific episode to watch because I know it'll help me feel validated and give me a greater perspective.
有时我会有强烈的某种情绪，然后挑出特定的一集来看，因为我知道这会让我觉得自己被理解，并给我带来更广阔的视角。
For instance, when I wanted to tell my boyfriend that I was in love with him, but was having a tough time getting it out, I watched first time in New York over and over again, just so I could realize I'm not alone and other people deal with this too.
例如，当我想要告诉男朋友我爱他，但又很难说出口时，我一遍又一遍地看《纽约初相识》，就是为了让我意识到我并不孤单，其他人也会面临这样的情况。
I even went so far as to play the episode for my boyfriend before I told him.
我甚至在向男朋友表白之前，把那一集放给他看了。
Oh my God.
天哪。
We used to do this thing before we had said it to each other, where we'd be gazing into each other's eyes and we'd go tight-lipped because neither of us was ready to say it to the other, but we both knew we wanted to say it to each other and we just didn't.
在我们向彼此表白之前，我们曾有过这样一幕：我们会凝视着彼此的眼睛，然后紧闭着嘴唇，因为我们俩谁都还没准备好对对方说出口，但我们俩都知道自己很想对对方说，只是没有说。
I showed him first time in New York and he knew I was trying to tell him I loved him, but all that could come out was falafel.
我给他看了《纽约初相识》，他知道我是想告诉他我爱他，但结果他嘴里只能吐出“沙三宝（Falafel）”这个词。
Sadly, my boyfriend and I broke up a little over four months ago.
遗憾的是，我和男朋友在四个多月前分手了。
I'm still madly in love with him and being able to turn to him for guidance during this emotional time has been such a gift.
我依然疯狂地爱着他，在这个充满情绪的时期，能够向这部剧寻求指导真是一份巨大的礼物。
I'm still hoping we'll work our way back to each other.
我仍然希望我们能重新回到彼此身边。
I at least can hold out hope that my yellow umbrella is out there and I just need to wait a little longer because he's coming as fast as he can.
我至少可以抱着这样的希望：我的黄色雨伞就在外面，我只需要再等一会儿，因为他正以最快的速度向我奔来。
Thank you for the gift of your art that has shaped my life, Ali.
感谢你们创作的艺术点亮了我的生活，阿里。
Well, that's beautiful.
嗯，太美好了。
Thank you, Ali.
谢谢你，阿里。
Yeah.
对。
You know, it made me think about something that I put this actually in liberal arts and it's attributed to David Foster Wallace, but a lot of stuff is attributed to him that he maybe this is said, but wasn't, didn't originate with him, but it was something along the lines of fiction is the antidote to loneliness.
你知道，这让我想起了一件事，我其实把它放进《自由艺术》里了，这归功于大卫·福斯特·华莱士，但很多话都被归功于他，也许这话是他说的，但也许不是，不是他原创的，但大意是虚构作品是孤独的解药。
And it's like that James Baldwin thing, you know, they said he felt so alone until he read Dostoyevsky and all these other great authors and realized, oh, they thought they had these feelings too.
这就像詹姆斯·鲍德温的那句话，你知道的，他们说他曾经感到如此孤独，直到他读了陀思妥耶夫斯基和所有这些伟大的作家，然后意识到，哦，原来他们也有过这些感受。
They had these thoughts too.
他们也有过这些想法。
I'm actually connected to humanity because, and this is another Wallace thing, like he says, we're all marooned in our own skulls and it's tricky to know like am I experiencing like am I alone here like like do other people feel an ache and hurt and yearn and laugh and is it all this in there's something about making art where you can see like oh it's such a relief when you see like oh yeah Robin has such a hard time saying she loves her boyfriend and so do I oh my god yeah what a relief you know I'm less alone in the world and I think that's one of the real gifts of of how I met your mother and all All great things, all great art and story, let's you know you're not alone.
我实际上是与人类相连的，因为——这也是华莱士的观点——他说我们都被困在自己的头脑中，很难弄清楚：我现在的经历是独一无二的吗？我在这里是孤独的吗？其他人也会感到痛苦、心碎、渴望和欢笑吗？这一切都在这里，而艺术创作的神奇之处就在于你能看到，哦，当你发现“哦，原来罗宾也很难对男友说出‘我爱你’，而我也是”时，那种如释重负的感觉真是太棒了。天哪，没错，多么解脱啊，你知道我在世界上不再孤单了。我认为这是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》以及所有伟大的事物、所有伟大的艺术和故事带来的真正礼物之一，它们让你知道你并不孤单。
Yeah, that's beautifully said.
是的，这话讲得太好了。
And I'm just going to say it, guys.
我要把它说出来，伙计们。
Falafel, Falafel.
沙三宝（Falafel），沙三宝（Falafel）。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies 网络和 Odyssey 联合呈现与发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Z 世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格。
artwork by John Morrow.
插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你喜爱的播客平台上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供了额外的音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目不可或缺的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他其他出版的文字作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
想了解更多关于如何做出改变的信息——本节目正在进行为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹款的持续活动——请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，它会跳舞的。